Das war's für heute, bis zum nächsten Mal, bis zum nächsten Mal, bis zum nächsten Mal.
Das war's für heute, bis zum nächsten Mal, bis zum nächsten Mal.
Das ist schon so ein bisschen das Meme bei uns auf der Arbeit, so nach dem Motto, aber wie sieht's aus, wenn wir einen Termin montags machen, dann finden sich alle immer furchtbar lustig und kecken sich einen ab. Aber da gibt's nix, montags bin ich nicht da. Genau, so sieht's aus.
Übrigens, guck mal, Leak, Handleak, Fingerleak. Ich hab mal wieder die Kamera eingeschaltet.
Leute, probieren was zu Flashchampen. Mal gucken, wie gut das funktioniert. Bin ich mal gespannt, weil, hab ich überhaupt FFZ und Gedöns hier? Moment, FFZ, Firefox. Es gibt so gewisse Sachen, die müssen sein. Ohne FFZ, FFZ geht nix.
Sagen wir mal, gibt's FFZ nicht offiziell irgendwo? Doch. Ach Moment, FFZ gibt's nicht mehr bei Add-ons? Echt nicht?
Na frag'n wir. Actual ProgChamp. Ach, FFZ gibt es ernsthaft nicht?
Ja, ja, ich weiß, ich weiß, aber warum gibt's das nicht im Add-on Store? Muss man nicht verstehen, oder? Add, okay.
Ja, weil wir brauchen schon die Emotes. Also ohne die Emotes geht hier gar nix. Emotes, please. FFZ. Moment. Moment, Moment, Moment. Wir haben Banner. Au. Sekunde. Jetzt wird's verwirrend.
Settings, Add-ons. Moment, ich hab beides? Nee, wo sind Extensions nochmal? Manage Extensions.
Äh, ach so. Ich hab Banner, Twitch, TV und FFZ. Ja gut, dann kann FFZ weg, das reicht. Eins, eins reicht. Also sonst zu viel. Heute schauen wir was, ja. Also vor allem, wie man das draufkriegt, schauen wir heute.
Warum ist das Stream in 1080p 48 FPS? Naja, dass es flüssiger ist. 48 FPS ist halt prog. Kann man FFZ-Emotes? Ach ja, ist doch alle Emotes, sind doch alle. Oh fuck, jetzt hab ich's zugemacht. Lul.
Wie ich nicht in der Lage bin, wieder das richtig zu bedienen. SevendingsTV, nee. So, lass mal kurz checken, ob die Emotes hier drin jetzt ordentlich funktionieren. Ja, passt.
Prog. Genau, für jedes Auge 24 FPS. Oh nee, ist Platoon-Musik.
Die Schrift ist überhaupt nicht... Ja, jetzt erkennt man wenigstens ordentlich was. So, schieben wir das mal hier oben hin. Okay, also Chat.
Ich hab gedacht, ich mach jetzt mal den Stream an, weil ich hätte das Ganze auch normalerweise ohne Stream gemacht. Ich bin mir gar nicht so sicher, ob man das zeigen darf, aber ich gehe mal stark davon aus, dass es kein Problem ist.
Weil das kann passieren, weil Android ist, näher, prinzipiell ein Open Source Betriebssystem und mit irgendwelchen ROMs und Sachen verletzt man ja nichts.
Zumal XDA ziemlich stark reglementiert ist, was man da anbieten darf und was nicht. Warum nicht? Ich mein, verboten ist es bestimmt nicht, außerdem haben wir das schon mal gemacht.
Verboten ist es nicht, ich kann mit meinem Tablet machen, was ich will. Zumal, ähm, was soll ich jetzt sagen, zumal es ja letztendlich dazu führt, dass die mir Tablets verkaufen.
Mal davon abgesehen, das ist ein altes Fire HD 10 von 2017. Guckt mal, das ist so eins. Das ist so eins und das gibt es ja gar nicht mehr.
Wahrscheinlich auch nicht mehr anfällig dafür. Tim True, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Exakt dafür will ich es machen. Das ist ja auch der Grund. Tim True, Dankeschön für den Sub. Das ist ja auch der Grund, warum ich das haben will. Ich hab ja schon welche, also ich hab ja schon mehrere hier als Home Automation Dashboard.
Und ich hätte jetzt gerne noch eins. Und ich hab halt noch ein Fire HD 10 von 2017, deswegen wird das jetzt geflashtchammt. Es gibt auch die Möglichkeit, dort so paar nervige Sachen auszustellen, wie diesen automatischen Bildschirmschoner und sowas.
Ähm, aber du hast trotzdem Probleme. Du kannst es nicht automatisch entlocken und sowas. Also geflasht ist tatsächlich die bessere Variante.
Proc. Du verdienst noch 70k. Ich hab ein iPad, aber was soll ich mit einem iPad? Ein iPad bringt dafür überhaupt nichts. Ein iPad ist so ziemlich das schlechteste Tablet, was es für Home Automation und Dashboards gibt.
Das iPad ist gut. Doch, doch, doch, es gibt noch ein 2021er Variante. Ich glaube, die lässt sich aber nicht flaschen. Das iPad ist gut zum normalen Benutzen, aber nicht hierfür. Kann man hier irgendwie in Bella Twitch TV die Schrift, die Font Size ein bisschen?
Z-Front Size, äh, 20? Keck. Wie viel Vergrößerung haben wir denn hier? Das ist doch gut, da kennt man wenigstens was. Mit was ist denn besser, so mit Farben oder? Ich muss den Dark Reader hier ausmachen.
Oh, Wonka. So ist gut. Der Prick Champ ist am Start. Ich hoffe nicht, dass es Prick Champt. Also das erste, was wir machen müssen ist, wir müssen das Ding routen.
Also ich habe mir die Anleitung so grob durchgelesen. Also was wir machen müssen ist folgendes. Wir müssen das Flaschen, wir müssen es routen und dann müssen wir irgendwelche komischen Dinger machen.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, vielleicht, vielleicht Prick Champt das dann auch. Ich hoffe nicht, ich hoffe nicht, dass es kaputt geht. Wenn es kaputt geht, werdet ihr es da sehen, ja. Prick Champ.
Hast du fleißig den ganzen Guide durchgelesen? Ja, ich habe im Vorfeld schon ein bisschen geguckt und da sind Dinger drinnen, die ich etwas, gibt es Aussetzer wirklich? Was macht Vodafone? Sekunde.
Nee, keinerlei Aussetzer. Nix. Null Drop Frames. Gar nichts. Absolut perfekt. Nee, sowas mache ich nicht. Man muss ja nicht scammen. Außerdem habe ich die Dinger schon seit zwei Jahren oder so.
Was wollte ich jetzt gerade? Achso, Guide. Ja, da stehen ein paar Dinger drinnen, die mich etwas, wie soll ich sagen, beunruhigen.
Da steht nämlich drinnen, wenn man eine neu, ich mache mal kurz ein bisschen größer. Da steht nämlich drinnen, wenn man eine neuere Firmware hat als 5.6.4.0, dann muss man downgraden und jetzt kommt es.
Also sprich, man muss sein Device kurz vorübergehend kaputt machen, damit man downcranen kann.
Ich hoffe halt, dass das temporär nicht zu dauerhaft wird. Ich mache mal kurz an und wir gucken mal nach.
Ich mache das mal kurz weg. Ich bin mir nämlich nicht ganz sicher, ob man am Anfang nicht irgendwie WLAN oder solche Geschichten sieht, deswegen mache ich mal kurz weg und dann gucken wir mal kurz die US Version nach, ob das passt.
Ich hoffe, wenn ich es einschalte, dass es jetzt nicht irgendwelche Updates macht und dass es dann nicht mehr flashbar ist.
Schauen wir mal kurz.
Ist natürlich sieht man das WLAN, war doch klar. Also Geräte Optionen, System Updates. Also guckt mal, diese US Version habe ich. Erkennt man das? Alter, ist das staubig.
MonkaS sieht gar nicht so staubig aus hier so. Sekunde. Erkennt man da was?
Das da 5 6 1 0. Jetzt ist halt die Frage.
Ja, ich weiß. Kann sein, dass ich mich ein bisschen spiele. Jetzt ist halt die Frage ist.
Wo steht es denn hier? Jetzt ist halt die Frage ist 5 6 1. Ist es 5 6 1 oder 5 6 10? Ich hatte 5 6 1.
Das heißt, das passt. Das passt. Dann kann ich. Ja, ich habe das seit 2018 oder so nicht nicht mehr angehabt. Ich habe was zwei Jahre reicht ja nicht. Seit zwei Jahren ist ja Corona. Das war lang vorher. Das ist seit 2018 habe ich den Kempel. Also es ist uralt.
Ich habe die korrekte Firma. Das ist Pog. So jetzt werden wir als erstes mal einen Snapshot machen.
Habe ich noch Platz? Kurz kurz checken. Sollte reichen. Snapshot von meiner Vm. Und jetzt versuchen wir das Ding mal.
Soll ich das mit dem Raspberry Pi machen? Kann man das ordentlich mit dem Raspberry Pi machen? Hat das jemand schon mal gemacht mit dem Raspberry Pi funktioniert das?
Weil dann könnte ich da liegen lassen und wir sehen was passiert. Weil ansonsten müsste ich müsste ich dann quasi hier hier rüber so da in die Richtung an Rechner stecken und dann sieht man nichts mehr.
In der Playlist sind eindeutig zu viele Splatoon Lieder. Ich weiß nicht. Viele feiern den Splatoon Soundtrack ja. Aber ich muss ehrlich sagen mir gefällt er nicht.
Das ist ein Raspberry Pi. Okay andere andere machen das. Andere machen das auch mit dem Raspberry Pi.
Dann dann können wir können es auch mit dem Raspberry Pi machen. Da kommt man vielleicht einfach auch besser dran.
Genau den den den Suas. Der Suas wird geroutet.
Komm ich mache das. Ich mache das. Ich mache das mit dem Raspberry Pi. Das ist wahrscheinlich besser.
Ich stelle mal die Kategorie um. Wir sind ja nicht Just Chatting. Wir sind ja Science. Oder? Five Head Science.
Wissenschaft und Technik. Wissenschaft und Technik. Nein das ist nicht Programmieren.
Okay dann machen wir es mit dem Raspberry Pi. Ist vielleicht gar nicht so blöd. Da muss ich kurz den Raspberry Pi holen. Mal gucken.
Ist da eine Micro SD drinnen? Ich Flash Champ mal kurz neu. Ich weiß nämlich nicht was wir zuletzt drauf gemacht haben. Schadet nichts. Ich Flash einfach mal schnell neu und dann per Netzwerk dran und gut ist.
Warum habe ich keinen USB Anschluss mehr frei? Kann ich den hier raus machen? Ja hoffentlich. Danach Hot Tube Stream. Klar bin ich da bekannt für.
Dann machen wir dann. So.
Erst mal kurz updaten. Schadet nichts. Jawoll. Eine Runde updaten. Nie verkehrt. Oh ne updaten ist eine blöde Idee. Wenn ich jetzt update muss ich Rebooten wegen Kernel updaten. Ich Reboote nicht.
Das ist dann ein Problem mit dem USB Stick. So lass mal kurz gucken. Wo ist der USB Stick? Wo hängt der? Hängt der überhaupt irgendwo? Ja. Chat. Seht ihr wo ist der USB Stick?
Onkess? Wo ist er? SDB. Da. Da. SDB. 32. 32G. Ja das sieht gut aus.
Das ist für mich das gleiche. Das ist doch eigentlich alles so eine rein rhetorische Sache. Programmieren, Softwareentwicklung. Wo fängt das eine an? Wo hört das andere auf? Irgendwo ist das doch alles Softwareentwicklung. So als Überbegriff.
Wie soll man denn Coding und Programmieren unterscheiden? Coding ist eins zu eins mehr oder weniger. Der englische Ausdruck. Na gut es wäre Programming. Aber trotzdem. Wo soll da der Unterschied sein?
SCB sind wir. Also dann machen wir mal. Sudo. Wie heißt das Ding? Pi Imager. Imager. Ja. Joe's OS. Wir wollen ein. Wir machen mal ein 32 Bit. Wir machen mal ein 32 Bit. Weil ich bin mir nicht sicher ob das mit 64 Bit alles schon gut klarkommt.
Ok. Raspberry Pi OS Lite. 32 Bit. Choose Storage. 32G Micro SD. Right. Would you like. Ach Moment Moment. Edit Settings. Pi. Moment.
Das muss man ja machen. Was ich mega bescheuert finde. Dass die keine default Passwort mehr haben. Ich weiß nicht wer sich das ausgedacht hat. Dass es eine gute Idee ist.
Selbst Scripting ist für mich kein Unterschied. Letztendlich ist das alles Programmieren. Oder man kann es auch unter Softwareentwicklung zusammenfassen.
Das sind bloß die coolen Leute die dann sagen wollen wie du verwendest Python oder Ruby. Das ist eine Script Sprache. Haha ich verwende Java. Das muss man so halbwegs kompilieren und ich bin viel geiler. Das ist total ein Blödsinn.
Das ist alles. Selbst wenn einer beispielsweise hauptsächlich. Keine Ahnung. Blockly verwendet oder so. Oder. Dann ist das auch Programmieren. Hackerman.
So. Muss man kurz den Switch einschalten. Das hier müsste. Super. Alter. Ist so viel Kabelsalat. So. Jetzt müsste der Switch angehen. Ja. Und irgendwie so halb auf halb acht hänge ich da an den Raspberry Pi. Und dann müsste es halbwegs passen.
So. You can continue. Das ist aber nett. Vom Flashchamp dass ich Continuen kann. Schießen wir mal noch einen Sync hinterher. Man weiß ja nie. So und jetzt.
Jetzt machen wir mal die Micro SD Karte hier rein. Sagt mal geht euch das auch immer so dass ihr die immer falsch herum rein macht. Sack. So. Jetzt brauchen wir hier das Netzwerk Kabel. Also das Netzwerk Kabel das hätte ich nicht ungünstiger. Nicht ungünstiger legen können hier hinten gerade.
So. Netzwerk Kabel in Raspberry Pi rein. USB anschließen.
Raspberry Pi sollte starten. Ich hoffe man sieht sieht man was. Seht ihr die LEDs. Ja gerade so.
Er sollte jetzt eigentlich was machen. Gleich booten von der von der Micro SD. Was ihn irgendwie nicht großartig interessiert.
Ah jetzt. Jetzt bootet er. Ok. Bootchamp. Der Raspberry Pi dass ich das die ganzen Flash Geschichten machen kann so dass ich also wenn ich mit Raspberry Pi mache kann ich es halt da drüben liegen lassen.
Und wir können ihr könnt zugucken. Ansonsten würde ich es am Rechner machen und dann müsste ich den Tablet aus der Kamera nehmen.
Mal kurz gucken was der Raspberry Pi für eine IP gekriegt hat. Raspberry Pi Wohnzimmer. Ist der das.
Nope. Könnte der aber durchaus sein. Raspberry Pi. Wo ist er denn.
Es müsste eigentlich der hier sein. Hallo Raspberry Pi willst du nicht eine IP mal kriegen. Was ist das jetzt schon wieder.
Also ohne Scheiß. Der hat echt Probleme. Der hat das letzte Mal schon immer diese Probleme gehabt. Könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern.
Wo wir fünf Mal wo wir das fünf Mal rein und raus gemacht haben bis es funktioniert hat.
Also von der Idee her müsste er eigentlich 138 haben. Das ist der alte Raspberry Pi aus dem Wohnzimmer. Macht er noch was.
Da macht nichts mehr oder. Jetzt blinkt er. Ganz merkwürdig. Hutet er noch. Ist eigentlich ok. Jetzt ist er wieder aus.
Also damit wollte ich mich jetzt eigentlich nicht weiter aufhalten. Ja. Da ist er doch. Es hat aber gedauert.
Guck mal wie lange wie lange wie lange er da jetzt rum gebootet hat. Gut. Der Raspberry Pi muss erstmal SSH Kigen.
Der muss ja immer erst die Festplatte resize und dass es funktioniert.
Ich habe doch gesagt Pi oder.
Im Y und Z oder so habe ich mich da ernsthaft vertippt jetzt bei oder was.
Ich glaube es nicht. Ich habe mich beim Image Passwort. Meine Güte. Also ich wüsste zwar nicht.
Ich habe das. Ich habe Raspberry Pi. Hab ich vielleicht Raspberry Pi geschrieben.
Egal. Ich flashe jetzt nochmal neu. Das geht schneller als hin und her. Probieren. Ok. Also choose OS. Anderes 32 Bit Lite Storage stehen da.
So customise. Also guck mal hier. Ich schreibe das jetzt hier oben rein. Raspberry. So schreibe ich das da unten jetzt auch rein.
Das da weg. Raspberry. Safe. Guckt hier. Könnt ihr Brut forsen. Right. Yes.
Das war wieder der Akt. Guck mal. Es ist auch schon gleich viel langsamer im Schreiben mit dem richtigen Passwort.
So während der Flasht. Wir gucken uns nochmal schnell die Anleitung an, dass ich dann weiß, was ich machen muss.
Also Linux System oder Micro USB Kabel habe ich am Start. Install Python 3 Pi Serial ADB. Fastboot DOS DOS Unix. Ok. Für Line Endings.
For Debian Ubuntu something like this should work. Ja gut das machen wir. Das gibt es schon bei Power.
Extract Attached Zip File. Amonet. Zues. V1.1.2. Zip. Ok. Enable ADB Settings. Starts Script.
Ne wir müssen nicht downcryden. Hier muss ich dann die Kamera ausmachen. Wobei das ist so klein da. Da seht ihr wahrscheinlich gar nichts da oben.
Ich mache es dann. Ich mache es dann auch ein bisschen größer. Sobald. Sobald was passiert. So dann.
Then press cancel and then not now. Ok. Ah ich soll das Initial Setup abbrechen. Ok. Dann macht ein Factory Reset.
Und dann kann ich ADB wieder enable. Alles klar. Na wenn ihr das sagt. So continue.
Hoffentlich kann ich jetzt mein Raspberry Pi anschmeißen. Ping. Gucken wir mal ob er wieder da ist.
So schauen wir mal. So ich lese mal Chat. Habe ja gerade mehr als genug Zeit für. Die Schriftart passt nicht wirklich jetzt.
So ist es schon besser. Erkennt man wenigstens ein bisschen was. Also. Layer 8 Problem. Ja so sah es aus.
Was habt ihr mit dem iPad. Ach so rein rein auf dem iPad fürs Studium oder so. Ich weiß nicht. Der hätte ich auch keinen Bock drauf.
So ein Laptop ist schon nicht verkehrt. Warum ich das flashe. Damit ich das ordentlich verwenden kann als Heimautomatisierungs Dashboard was an der Wand hängt.
Wenn die Dinger mit dem mit diesem. Wie heißt denn das Ding eigentlich von Amazon Fire OS. Ich glaube Fire OS heißt das.
Da kannst du beispielsweise den Bildschirm nicht dauerhaft entlocken und du hast so einen komischen Amazon Bildschirm Schoner und sowas.
Das eignet sich einfach nicht dafür. Ansonsten ohne Scheiß muss man ja auch mal sagen das Fire Tablet ist richtig gut.
Also normalerweise muss man das weder flaschen noch irgendwie groß anpassen und die Werbung ist gar nicht mal so extrem störend.
Es gibt zwar. Also es gibt die ein oder anderen Tricks wie man die weg kriegt. Ja da könnt ihr dann selbst gucken.
Aber preisleistungsmäßig ist das Fire Tablet wirklich unschlagbar gut. Alter wie lange braucht der Raspberry Pi bitte schön.
Raspberry Pi auf. Mach hinne.
Das Ding hat das letzte Mal schon immer so Probleme gehabt. Vielleicht. Aber ich werde den garantiert nicht wegschmeißen.
Weil das ist ein Raspberry Pi 4.
Aber das ist ein Raspberry Pi 4.
Aber das ist Ein Luego degradieren.
Aha, wir sind am Start, keygen-r, hi-ed, yes, aha, jetzt funktioniert's auch, ok, update,
ok alles klar, dann wollen wir mal anfangen, also was brauchen wir denn um das ganze zu
flash-champen, python3, python-serial-adb, fastboot-dos2-unix, alles klar, machen wir
das nochmal, erstmal upgrade, schade nix wenn wir da aktuell sind und dann update, software
beim fetten auto-konzern, jetzt eher user-interface oder micro-controller-kram oder auto-zeug,
also ich geh davon aus, dass die Leute, die das touch-display designen bei einem auto
wo andere Leute sind, die irgendwelche Steuerungen programmieren dafür, ja, dann hast du's
mit der android-toolbox ausgeschaltet alles, oder du hast die Version gekauft ohne Werbung,
wenn das bei dir so ist, doch bin ich, bin ich immer noch, bin ich immer noch, aber mal
gucken wie lang noch, auf raspberry pi, update, gib ihm, ok, also, installen, machen wir ein
paar Dinge, von denen ich, weiß ich nicht, wo ich denke, dass man die vielleicht braucht,
es könnte auch sein, dass ich mit der toolbox auto-updates ausgeschaltet habe, da hab ich
Glück, so, als rebooten wir einmal noch und dann können wir endlich anfangen, mal gucken,
so, ist er wieder da, nope, er bootet echt 5 Stunden von der micro sd-karte, wie kann
das sein, das ist normalerweise super zackig, der blinkt auch, ich weiß warum das so lange
dauert, ich hab den umgestellt, dass der über usb ssd bootet, das heißt, der muss jetzt
erstmal timeouten, dass er überhaupt von der micro sd-karte anfängt, das wird es
natürlich erklären, so, auf gehts, also, was müssen wir jetzt machen, erstmal das
den rooten, hier, den krempel installieren, das ist doch schon alles drauf, oder, keck,
gut, tut gut, hat er irgendwas nicht gefunden, nope, erstmal den ganzen krempel als abhängigkeiten
interessieren, da, ja, ich weiß, ich weiß, ich weiß, ich weiß, ich weiß, ich weiß, ich
weiß, ich weiß, ich weiß, es ist relativ einfach, wie der ffmpeg handeln müsste sein,
Copy? Ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, wie geht denn das?
FFmpeg, Copy, ja.
Minus C, Copy, Output, Output, MP, oh.
Minus, Minus, I.
This should work. Without transcoding, re-encoding.
Oh.
Hm.
You can accept an input stream with FFmpeg.
Ja, macht es. Die HD Tablets sind pork.
So, also wo sind wir stehen geblieben?
Also wir haben den Krempel installiert und jetzt soll ich was? Download Extract Attached Zip. Wo ist die Attached Zip?
Monkabum, was für eine Zip?
Wo ist es? Wo ist, wo ist, wo ist das Attachede?
Muss man dafür registriert sein?
Das da?
Das da, ha?
Nee, hat Storm geloaded. Ach so, Moment, ich muss doch von Raspberry Pi downloaden.
Copy Download Link, exellent.
Index HTML, ja, genau das, das ist das was ich haben will.
Copy, Alter.
Copy, Link.
Jetzt, hoffentlich geht es jetzt.
Index HTML.
Warte mal, ist das vielleicht die Datei?
Das ist die Datei, die heißt einfach Index HTML jetzt.
Ja, super.
Index HTML, Keckl Punkt Zip.
She baited, Alter.
Warte mal hier kurz.
Ja, Flashchamp.
Okay, unzip.
Okay, so, und jetzt.
Enable ADB in Developer Settings, alles klar.
Ich mach mal kurz hier das Tablet ab, weil wir müssen es dann eher in Raspberry Pi stecken.
Okay, in Developer Settings. Chat, weiß jemand aus dem Kopf noch, wie das geht mit Developer Settings?
Man geht irgendwie auf Hilfe? Nee.
Man geht auf Geräte Optionen, Entwickler Optionen und dann muss man 9 mal irgendwie draufdrücken.
Ah ja.
Sie sind Entwickler, Leute, habt ihr es gehört? Ich bin offiziell, Amazon sagt das, ich bin offiziell Entwickler jetzt.
Entwickler Optionen.
Und jetzt ADB aktivieren.
Exzellent, so.
ADB ist aktiviert.
Und jetzt schließen wir das Ding mal an den Raspberry Pi an und gucken mal, was abgeht.
Wenn überhaupt was abgeht.
Wir schauen uns das USB 2.0 Port an. Man weiß es ja nie.
So.
Angeschlossen ist es.
Feier mit schwachem Ladegerät verbunden. Ja, das ist mir egal. Egal ob ich mit einem schwachen. Oh, man sieht mich. Leak, Leute, leak.
Ja, wird schon, wird schon passen, denke ich.
Okay.
Man sieht Schicko auf dem Bild.
Welches HD 10 ist das von 2017?
So, und jetzt okay, ich habe ADB an. Hat er das jetzt auch erkannt?
Amazon, hier, da, zack, Serial Number, das sieht gut aus.
So, und jetzt gehe ich wo rein?
Enable Startscript.
Hier wahrscheinlich, oder?
Step 1, SH.
Ne, als Sudo brauchen wir das, wir sind schon gut.
Was passiert denn da überhaupt? Wir gucken mal kurz rein, was der... Alter, was, wie?
Anzeige ist raus, Alter, kein Wim drauf.
Wichtigste überhaupt.
Ganz Nanokeks.
Wim, Step 1, was macht denn der da überhaupt?
Es sieht, es hält sich in Grenzen, oder?
Okay.
Step 1, not running.
Oh, ich sollte nicht so viel Enter drücken, wer weiß, was da passiert.
Device will now reboot into recovery.
Seht ihr irgendwas?
Ich sehe da nichts.
Ah, Moment.
Ich muss erst USB Debugging zulassen.
Was?
Was will das Ding von mir?
Hä?
Script, was willst du mir sagen?
Kann es sein, dass ich das schon mal geroutet habe, oder so?
Es ist ein New Line, so ist es.
Ich glaube, das ist verwirrt, das Script, oder?
Ich meine, unabhängig davon, ob ich Route habe oder nicht...
Was?
Ach, das hätte ich vorher machen sollen, oder was?
Das hätte ich vorher machen müssen.
Okay, das ist natürlich Five-Hat-Time, das habe ich nicht gelesen.
Also ich muss was, ich muss das da...
Binary, für was?
Monka, was muss ich jetzt alles machen?
Gar nicht, einfach nur das Binary runterladen, oder?
Wo ist das Binary?
Hier, Release.
Alles klar.
Ach, ich kacknup.
Copy-Download-Link.
Okay, also, nach Bin muss ich jetzt?
Ach, da ist das nicht, okay.
Index, Index, Index-HTML, alles klar.
Unzip, wir unzipen jetzt den Index-HTML.
Easy.
Und wo hat er jetzt was, wo hat er jetzt was entpackt?
Was muss ich, was muss ich denn da jetzt moveen?
Welche, welche, welche, welche muss ich denn da jetzt moveen?
Oder, oder einfach das Gesamte?
Und Unpack Binary.
Nee, ich glaube, Step One?
Nee, so funktioniert das nicht.
Ist das jetzt für die Zielplattform oder für meine Plattform vom Raspberry Pi?
Arm?
Probieren wir es nochmal.
Jetzt sollte es ja gehen.
Ah!
Your device will be reset to factory defaults.
Press Enter to continue.
Leute, ich hab ein bisschen Schiss, dass man irgendwas sieht von meinem Amazon-Account oder so.
Ich, ich zeig's euch nicht.
Ich presse jetzt Enter, ohne dass ihr das seht.
Was?
No device emulators.
Das ging jetzt ja nicht so, nicht so schnell, oder?
Pricked!
Das hat er überhaupt nicht rebooted.
Der hat richtig jebaited.
Der hat überhaupt nichts rebooted.
Oh!
Jetzt, jetzt hat er rebooted.
Der weiß auch nicht so genau, was er macht, oder?
Rebooting into recovery.
Okay Leute, hier er rebooted. Guckt mal da.
Seht ihr, er rebooted.
Reboot Champ.
Und wie geht's jetzt weiter?
Der macht jetzt, okay, der macht factory reset.
Das ist jetzt erstmal langweil, langweilig Champ.
Start script, device will into recovery and perform a factory reset.
Blablabla, das haben wir nicht.
When you are back at initial setup.
Okay, er rebooted weiter. Guckt hier, er ist am Reboot Champen.
Ich muss auf jeden Fall wieder ADB re-enable, sonst funktioniert's nicht.
Schauen wir mal.
Gucken wir mal, ne?
Also aktuell macht er nichts, außer zu resetten.
Optimizing system storage.
This will take approximately 10 minutes to complete.
Na, das ist aber krasse Optimierung, die hier läuft.
Massive optimizing.
Ich glaube nicht wirklich, dass es 10 Minuten braucht.
Da steht bloß was von 10 Minuten, dass die Leute nicht gleich
bei der Hotline anrufen nach 30 Sekunden.
Wobei es gibt keine Hotline, aber ihr wisst, was ich meine.
Okay, da muss ich dran denken.
Ich muss ADB re-enable, ganz wichtig.
ADB muss re-enabled werden.
Kennt man da irgendwas drauf?
Er optimized system storage.
Genau, ADB re-enable nicht vergessen.
Mach ich gleich.
Sobald er fertig optimized ist.
Auf, gib ihm.
Nicht Amazon.
Google, mach hin.
Optimize mal schneller.
Muss wahrscheinlich noch die restlichen Sachen schnell
in die Cloud hochladen, bevor er es gesettet.
Massive exciting.
Warte, Fortschrittsbalken zugucken.
Guck mal, er ist schon bei 40%.
Das ist doch Schwachsinn, was da steht, oder?
Der macht doch sicherlich was ganz was anderes,
als system storage und applications zu optimisern.
Das ist wahrscheinlich der Reset, da steht bloß irgendwas da,
wo sich die Leute darüber freuen können.
So nach dem, oh, es macht mein Tablet schneller.
Das ist so wie mein Vater, der hat sich früher immer
Tune-up-Utilities 2005 und Zeug installiert,
falls jemand diesen Blödsinn kennt.
Was, 2005, 1995, Tune-up 95 und sowas hat er sich installiert.
Und war er der Meinung, es geht gar nicht ohne mehr.
Also sein PC wäre so langsam ohne.
Da würde ich mir mal Gedanken machen.
Wird das eine Installation mit Micro-G?
Das weiß ich noch nicht genau.
Erstmal muss ich es routen.
Ich brauche keine Google-Services.
Ich brauche F-Droid danach.
Eventuell den Aurora-Store für den Kiosk-Browser.
Dann müsste ich die Lizenz für den Kiosk-Browser umziehen
auf das neue Tablet.
Aber das hat ja zum Glück einen guten Trial-Modus.
Wie sieht es aus, Optimizer?
Okay, 70%, oder?
Zeig mal.
Ja, ja, ist fast fertig.
Fast durch.
Guck hier.
Hat es fast geschafft.
Meine rotierenden HDD.
Also Tune-up 95 hat glaube ich wenig gebracht,
was Festplatte angeht.
Du kannst sie defragmentieren.
Ansonsten, was willst du großartig machen bei einer HDD,
außer defragmentieren?
Oh, oh, er ist fertig, Leute.
Er ist fertig.
Lul.
Amazon will Zeug von mir haben.
Also.
United States.
US.
Ja, Kikona.
Eindeutig.
Continue.
Back.
Wie hat er gesagt, geht das hier mit dem Setup?
When you are back at initial setup, you can skip registration by selecting a Wi-Fi network,
then press cancel and then not now.
Okay.
Wi-Fi network.
Cancel.
Not now.
Ah.
Skip fire setup.
Skip six head.
Alter.
Okay, es ist ziemlich veramazonifiziert wieder.
So, und jetzt muss ich ADB wieder anmachen.
Machen wir.
Device Options.
Sie sind now ein Developer.
Hoho.
Sind mir geil, wir sind ein Developer, Leute.
Yes.
USB debugging aktiviert.
Okay.
Alles klar.
Und jetzt geht es weiter mit.
Step two.
Now flash your device will reboot into TWRP.
Oh, jetzt wird es ernst, Leute.
Step two.
Brickchamp.
Bye bye, HD10.
Okay, es bootet, Leute, es bootet, es bootet.
Was macht sonst noch irgendwas?
Kurz gucken.
Nee, aktuell.
Oh, was ist das?
Oh, was ist hier los?
Das kann ich nicht lesen.
Sekunde.
Oh.
Five head time ist hier angesagt.
Guckt mal hier.
Ich dreh es mal so, dass ihr es lesen könnt.
Das Problem ist, wenn ihr es lesen könnt.
Wenn ihr es lesen könnt, kann ich es nicht lesen.
Tja.
Okay.
Also, was haben wir jetzt?
TWRP
WRP can leave your system partition unmodified.
To make it easier for you to take official updates,
it will be enabled to prevent the stock from replacing.
Aha.
Okay.
Und wie geht es jetzt weiter?
You can now install Magisk from there.
From there.
Was sagt mir das jetzt?
Ich kann Magisk installieren.
Will ich Magisk überhaupt?
Oder war es das jetzt?
Ist es jetzt fertig?
Fertig? Going back to stock?
Das brauche ich nicht, oder?
Magisk.
Das heißt, das war es jetzt.
Oh, ist es jetzt ausgegangen?
Ah ne, geht noch.
So, you can now install, will ich ja gar nicht.
Ich glaube, wir müssen jetzt hier weitermachen.
Was will der eigentlich gerade von mir hier, was ist das?
Swipe to unlock.
Massive.
Ich glaube, es geht jetzt weiter mit der anderen Anleitung.
Ja, das haben wir jetzt ja gemacht.
Das haben wir jetzt ja gemacht.
Do not update Magisk.
Aha.
Kein Magisk.
Wir lassen Magisk weg.
Also.
Downloads Google Drive.
Ok.
Äh.
Und wie installiere ich das jetzt?
Was davon brauche ich jetzt?
Also meine bisschen Anleitung wäre ja vielleicht nicht verkehrt gewesen.
Und wie geht das jetzt?
Oder muss ich doch hier noch weitermachen?
Ne.
Also Google Drive.
So, hier.
Moment.
Ja.
Wir wollen haben.
Was ist das zuletzt geänderte?
Hier, fünfter, siebter.
Wo wir haben.
Das da.
Äh, hallo?
Kann man Google Drive nicht irgendwie den Link über den Rechtsklick bekommen?
Muss ich jetzt allen Ernstes ein X-Forwarding machen, dass ich da über den Browser downloaden kann oder was?
Keck.
Ich fasse es nicht.
Muss ich Chrome installieren?
Ok, ich könnte es ja runterladen und rüber SCPen.
Das wäre klar.
Warum mache ich es eigentlich so kompliziert?
Ich kann es einfach runterladen und rüber kopieren.
Nein, wir machen X-Forwarding. X-Forwarding sieht immer stylisch aus.
So, und was ist hier in diesem anderen Ordner drinnen?
TWRP?
Ich meine, vielleicht hat er eine Anleitung hier auf GitHub.
Nee.
Raspberry Pi. Komm, install liter mal.
Man sofort mal klicken.
Es kann Infinity-Skeletons sein.
Nimm doch mal die鮮.
Nimm doch mal die interesting.
Und dann wohl tongue, und
Rass attitude-switch ausd impresi kann concealerer...
Die Bilder darauf noch mal wieder überqueren können,
가ât넯ㄺ,
Installier mal.
So ein Chrome ist ja wahrscheinlich mit allen Abhängigkeiten auch mal 800MB oder sowas
groß.
Das brauch ich schon kurz.
Chat mir ist es jetzt einfach mal danach.
So genug und jetzt wieder.
Mensch mach hier ne, weil ihr seid Chat, weil ihr seid, so jetzt aber gut.
Jetzt Gnome installieren, du meinst den Scheiß Gnome soll ich installieren?
Die Weeps sind happy, sowas das sein.
Also jetzt 96% komm mach.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Leute falls ich den Sub so übersehen hab, sorry tut mir leid, ich weiß alle Subs zu
schätzen.
Oder wie sagen die Ami-Streamer immer, ich appreciate das, das klingt so richtig cringe
auf Deutsch.
So machen wir SSH-Y und gucken ob jetzt der Chrome aufgeht.
Hey wir haben den Chrome auf dem Raspberry Pi auf Pog, Pog, Massive Pog, huge Geschwindigkeit
der Browser.
Also das hier, dieser Browser jetzt, nur damit ich euch nicht verwirre, dieser Browser
hier der läuft auf dem Raspberry Pi, nur die Grafikausgabe ist bei mir, das heißt wenn
ich jetzt hier was runter lade, dann lande das auch, auch auf dem Raspberry Pi, also
nicht auch, auch sondern auch nur auf dem Raspberry Pi.
Wunder der Technik, ja es ist leider relativ langsam das Wunder der Technik, also X-Formatting
ist nix, obwohl man schnelle Sachen machen möchte, aber es geht, dafür geht es auch
von VMs aus Indien.
So, ist es eigentlich Lineage oder Lineage, so das ist runtergeladen, sudo, ok wie geht
es jetzt weiter, wie flash ich jetzt was, ich hab legit kein, chat ihr müsst mir helfen,
ich hab wirklich keine Ahnung wie das funktioniert jetzt, ich hab jetzt den ROM hier drauf, ok,
wir machen jetzt, ihr dürft jetzt backseiten, das dürft ihr sonst nie, jetzt dürft ihr
das, ok also, ich hab jetzt geswiped um Modifications zu erlauben, so geswiped um Modifications
zu erlauben, was mach ich jetzt, mount, mount, ah das sieht man schlecht ne, so hier viel
besser, so exellent, so machen das man was sieht, so mount, select partitions to mount,
da ist keine Anleitung, select partitions to mount, mount system partition, ne, ich will
flashen, das ist richtig, ich will flashen, ich will flash, flash chatten, also will ich,
will ich install machen, install image, ne, die Datei ist nicht auf dem Tablet, ne, ne,
ich hab, ich habe, das ROM hab ich hier, Moment, home, pie, downloads, das da, mount um rüber
zu kopieren, ok, Leute das ist jetzt ein bisschen kompliziert für meinen Hirn, weil ich navigiere
über die Kamera, das heißt links ist eigentlich gar nicht links wie ich meine Hand bewegen
muss, also doch mount, data cache storage, also storage, ne, also das heißt es ist schon
gemountet oder wie und muss ich jetzt mit adb irgendwas kopieren, einfach im pie das Tablet
auf, Moment, ach so, ne, ach, ne das ist was anderes, ich hab hier nichts zum mounten,
ich hab nur meine SD Karte, also hier ist nichts zum mounten, hm, der hat aber erkannt,
der hat aber irgendwas erkannt hier, ok, adb mount, ne, ok, das kann nicht so schwierig
sein, Leute, das kriegen wir schon raus, select storage, internal storage, was ist mtp, media
transfer protokoll, ok, chat, das kriegen wir raus, so schwer kann das nicht sein, ich
mein ich brauch im Prinzip hier einfach nur ne disc, was unter advanced sideload, ok,
fifa chat, advanced adb sideload, swipe to start sideload, der chat ist wieder mvp, guck
jetzt haben wir sideloaden aktiviert und jetzt macht man was, adb sideload, am Moment muss
man das erst anzippen, lädt man das als zip den rom oder anzippt man das vorher, nicht
anzippen, ok, adb sideload, aha, und jetzt, boah, alter, was ist das für ein speed,
ja, ok, es geht, komm, wir sind bei 10%, es ist gar nicht so langsam, wie ich gedacht
hab, wir sind bei 10%, wir haben jetzt ne halbe minute, das geht, das geht, 5 minuten sind
wir fertig, high speed, flashen, was bei mtp ist es schneller, ne, das ist wahrscheinlich
wegen usb, einfach, das ist usb 2, ich glaub mehr hat das tablet gar nicht, wollen wir
mal kurz schauen was das tablet hat, ich glaub ich hab nur nen usb 2 kabel dran, ich dachte
das reicht, fire hd 10 2017, spex, was sind das für scam seiten, usb, ne, hat nur usb
2.0, ja dann ist klar warum das so langsam ist, also leute ich bin wirklich relativ planlos,
warum hat er hier irgendwelche twrp versionen hingeschmissen, wenn ich doch twrp hier schon
installiert hab, oder muss das geupdatet werden oder sowas, du kannst twrp auch, warum bringt
mir das was, ich glaub die gehen einfach von aus, jeder noob weiß wie man nen android
flasht, aber ich hab keine ahnung, aber wir werden es ja gleich wissen, guck mal 35%
schon, easy, geht doch richtig zackig, leute wir dürfen einfach nicht zugucken, dann geht
schneller, geplockt, progress blocked, aha, so ist das also, Achtung, wer hat's gesehen,
die prozents sind schei, genau, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du,
du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du,
Back
So
Jetzt müsst ihr mir sagen
Ich vermute mal install
Oder install wahrscheinlich
Install
Alter wo hat er das jetzt hin gepackt
Über sideload hast du das komplett geflasht
Achso
Ach wirklich
Der flasht das direkt
Da muss ich nichts mehr auswählen oder wie
Achso
Na dann
Easy
Was soll ich noch vipe
Aber lösche ich das dann nicht wieder
Wenn ich das was ich gerade geflasht habe
Oder vipe das nur quasi die
Die settings
Und nicht das image
Ok vipe
Was
Was steht da
Most of the time the only vipe that you need
Ok
Was soll ich jetzt swipen oder format data sagen
Swipen oder format data
Was will der jetzt von mir sagen
Advanced
Ich hab doch vorher
Ein factory reset gemacht
Warum sollte ich da irgendwas swipen
Muss da bestimmt nichts swipen
Ok ich muss das mal kurz so machen
Dass ich was lesen kann da drauf
Ok
So
Ich muss das mal kurz so machen
Dass ich was lesen kann da drauf
Haken by art
Cache data und dann
Cache
Data
Also vipe
Wenn du von stock
Zu custom gehst
Ok
Art Data Cache also so ja pass auf jetzt ist gleich geprickt und jetzt und jetzt wird
geswiped jetzt wird geswiped wie das wars Reboot und jetzt Reboot Reboot und dann sollte
er den Rom starten da bin ich mal gespannt und jetzt Prickchamp
Prick Prickchamp da startet irgendwas von Amazon das ist glaube ich immer das gleiche
beim starten
ne mach das vielleicht ist das jetzt schon an ne vielleicht vielleicht braucht es auch
einfach noch ein bisschen
Forcechamp Forcechamp ich hab doch vorher gevibe
genau nicht hingucken chat wir müssen im Moment ich muss das abdecken
ich hab doch gevibe chat
wir warten jetzt einfach guck mal ich mein mehr als kaputt gehen kann es ja nicht
im Moment steht da überhaupt noch irgendwas drauf jetzt zeig mal kurz her
unten steht fastbootmode ich glaube das ist schlecht oder fastbootmode steht unten
nicht schlecht nur der falsche modus was auch immer soll ich vielleicht mal so
vielleicht weil das noch per android die bug zeug dran ist vielleicht weil er noch
irgendwie amazon tablets weil er jetzt noch erkannt hat dass das okay ich ich
ziehe mal das kabel ab und dann schalten wir mal aus gucken was passiert
ne guck mal mal
und jetzt das steht jetzt amazon sollte da nicht eigentlich direkt das logo
kommen zum starten oh leute es booted guck dir mal easy doch nicht doch nicht
okay jetzt schließe ich mal zu na gut geladen habe ich ja schon auf 50 prozent
eins vor brick ok das booten dauert wirklich ewig
gleich kernelpanic gibt es eigentlich noch irgendwelche anderen custom sachen
außer lineage os was man so kennt und wo es für andere wobei wobei das bringt
mir ja nix wenn es sowas gibt es müsste hier irgendjemand in rom gebastelt haben
dafür kommt mal es ist gebootet es ist es ist gebootet was kalix os was nie
gehört noch nie gehört es ist jetzt fertig muss jetzt was machen
ah next english united kingdom jawohl kakona ne united states kakona hell
yeah kakona ok ich muss jetzt nur gucken ich will keine wehler an sachen
liegen your time zone wie wäre es mit europe so was berlin ja date time alles
alles gut ja ok wifi network so ihr könnt erst wieder gucken wenn ich mich
wehler an verbunden habe wehler an password ok da muss ich kurz da muss ich
kurz nachgucken auf den zweiten bildschirm kein liegt ich kann mir mein
wehler password immer noch nicht merken das ist auch zu lang mittlerweile aber
sind normale wörter also
wehler ok da kommt schon mal wehler antrenne ford ist schon mal gut so wenn
ich mich jetzt nicht verschrieben habe sollte es funktionieren obtaining ip
ok nice next location service
next next protect your tablet mit einem pin keck will ich nicht start ok
nice ich glaube es funktioniert ich glaube ich glaube das geht einfach jetzt
guckt mal ich glaube ich glaube das ist einfach jetzt das tut jetzt einfach so
jetzt brauche ich ich brauche nur eine app da drauf und das ist na gut ich
brauche chrome das heißt ich brauche auf jeden fall google shit also wie macht
man das jetzt am ersten also normalerweise sagt mir mal ob das ob das
sinn ergibt normalerweise würde ich genau normalerweise würde ich mir jetzt
droid drauf hauen und noch den aurora store drauf hauen
wieso chrome weil chrome web rtc kann ich brauche nicht chrome stimmt auch gar
nicht ich muss den android web view aktualisieren nicht nicht chrome ist ich
muss den android web view ins aktualisieren sowas ich komm plötzlich
nicht das brauche ich weil der weil der neue web rtc kann letztendlich ist unter
android das meiste auch chrome ok das heißt wir installieren es mal habe ich
auch ein browser drauf irgendwas ja ich habe den eingebauten android browser
zwar eine blöde frage chat aber also ich meine ich bin ich ich bin nicht so der
android kenner ja was ist denn hier das start was ist denn hier eigentlich das
startmenü normalerweise ist das startmenü hier in der mitte das ja so da aber das
ist der browser hat es ein startmenü dass ich sehen kann was alles installiert
ist
wahrscheinlich
hochwischen ach so alter man das ist aber auch laufen irgendwas anderes oder
hochwischen muss man
die browser
ok da installieren wir jetzt den f droid store kann so nicht tippen das
funktioniert nicht
ich verwende normalerweise kaum Android Geräte ich habe nur welche an der wand
hängen so f droid allow
gut oh der download hat nicht funktioniert
wenn ich nach f droid store suche kommt als erstes queen elisabeth was hatten
die damit zu tun ok so download ist fertig
sag mal die downloads sind dann hier wahrscheinlich unter files gehe mal von
aus ups
downloads hier guck da ff droid und was will der von mir kann auch keine lesen
alter your tablet personal data are more vulnerable ja ja
yes install application
du du du du du app install open so update repositories
ganz schön lang für
wieso das nicht schon dabei ist keine ahnung ok
aus irgendwelchen gründen kann er nichts updaten das auch geil also das von
unten wischen muss ich mich wirklich noch dran gewöhnen das ist ziemlich
sixhead ich updating repositories guck mal es kann schön fleißig fleißig am
downloaden ok das dauert jetzt
gib ihm
nein nein nicht ausgehen alter oh jetzt hat er es gecheckt ok search
au rora store install kennst du ja das kenne ich
install so und danach kann ich mein system chrome chrome view was ich mit
web rtc vor habe ich will die kameras beispielsweise anzeigen wenn es bei mir
in der tür klingelt switchte automatisch auf die kamera von hoftor
und hof dafür dann das geht über web rtc warum noch ein store dass ich das
zeug installieren kann was nicht über f droid geht
so next
next next next
ist aber ich komme echt vor wieder wie der letzte mensch der finish so lock in
so und jetzt brauche ich nämlich jetzt muss ich den den web view aktualisieren
weil er garantiert uralt ist android system web view auf den aktuellen auf
wegen der aktuelle chrome version so und dann müsste eigentlich alles
funktionieren
ich glaube das war es dann do you want to install this application yes alles
jetzt installiert oder nicht open ja ok park so alles klar dann probieren das
mal aus ich starte mal meine home assistant meine home assistant vm hier
ich meine ich werde ich mach das jetzt nicht mit meiner einem echten home
assistant weil er da zu viel sachen sieht und so viel zu viele leaks hat und
haben und alles aber das tablet mal ordentlich integrieren können wir jetzt
ja mal machen
so ich werde jetzt die app noch installieren hier ja reboot geben
hier beste vm reboot das da werde ich jetzt noch installieren fully fully
kiosk browser
der hat mittlerweile sogar eine home assistant integration werde ich euch
gleich zeigen do you want to install this application yes
open sehr schön so alles klar da sind wir got it ok
dann starten wir mal unseren home assistant und können das dann mal
integrieren ach so ha ne feierball technisch komme ich da gar nicht hin
mit dem tablet aber das na gut das macht nix
ich zeige ich schalte das mal frei ich zeige es euch trotzdem ach so welche ip
hatten mein mein tablet eigentlich sieht man das hier in den in den wifi
settings irgendwo more settings 22 hat das
122 und es war die piler muss man bisschen weg dass ein bisschen platz
fürs tablet ist 122 den brauchen nämlich eine feste ip ja 100 22 alles klar fast
ja die sind jetzt gut aber das ist ein 2017er was ich hab so das ist mein
android tablet oder high high performance wifi
guckt euch das mal an
alter wie schlecht kommen an wie langsam ist denn bitteschön
was ist mit dem wlan in dem ding los
es ist ja abverklangsam oder liegt es am raspberry pi nicht wirklich ich mein
mein access point ist ein raum weiter daran liegt es bestimmt nicht
ich meine wir könnten wir könnten wir könnten mal einen iperf oder so machen
ich war mal kurz den speed test von dem ding kurz mal kurz mal schauen kurz kann
jetzt nicht machen wie ein p-leak wenn die latenz hatte nicht unbedingt was
über die über für die übertragungsrate zu sagen aber machen wir mal die luft
ist heute zu langsam ja so sieht es aus ok also geschwindigkeitsrekorde gewinnt
das tablet ja wirklich nicht vielleicht ist auch der amazon eigene rom ein
bisschen schneller pressemeldung von rockstar zu den leagues ok moment das
muss ich mir kurz angucken
was sagen sie
ok zeig mal kurz ok der speed test ist richtig langsam keck
in 40 44 mb m bit
das ist tatsächlich ziemlich langsam
da ist das andere aber schneller
ich bekomme keine on ich bekomme keine tastatur hier drinnen
also ich muss mal kurz groben nach installieren
glaube hier ist irgendwas hier ist irgendwas im arsch
so also was schreiben wir denn hier zeigt mal her wie recently stuff hat der
network intrusion in ja exes development footage at this time ok also typische
nichtsagende pressemeldung oder das ja also ok also die pressemeldung ist ja
komplett nicht sagen gewesen jetzt hätte man sich auch sparen können oder
wisst ihr jetzt besser bescheid nachdem ihr das gesehen habt 100 prohörers jetzt
ist natürlich alles klar
das ist ja wirklich absolut nicht sagen der aus nicht sagen der presse
erklärung wieder hätten die irgendwas zum release datum oder irgendwas
irgendwas sinnvoll aber so einfach nur ja aber zumindest ich wollte es kann ich
wollte es gerade sagen zumindest weiß man jetzt es war auf jeden fall echt das
liegt
aber das war vorher auch deswegen weil die leute immer gesagt haben das ist
gefegt das sah mir die ganze zeit schon ziemlich legit aus so ich habe mal
kurz chrome installiert weil irgendwas mega lahm ist in diesem on board browser
erst install so was wollte ich jetzt machen
sekunde home assistant starten home assistant starten habe ich gemacht
ha ha
ich wollte firewall freischaltung kurz machen dass ich euch was zeigen kann
das mal kurz einrichten so also ip firewall add new so source 192.168.1.1.2
zu 192.168.2.1.3.2 alles klar except
meine firewall regeln sind procken die funktionieren nicht warum nicht
ach jetzt jetzt gehen sie oder was es gibt gibt sagen die muss man nicht
verstehen
da zehn habe ich nicht ich habe ein paar so ist chrome jetzt installiert
chat mein tablet ist einfach aus das tablet hat sich gerade einfach resettet
ich glaube das war kann es sein dass die batterie leber ich sollte es ich
glaube ich war wieder anschließen es kann sein dass die batterie leber
überhitzt die batterie ist angeblich noch 40 prozent dann weiß ich auch
nicht aber aber leute chrome chrome geht a play services den not supported
jetzt geht es doch chrome weiß nicht chrome weiß nicht was ist was es will
es sagte es ist nicht supportet ohne play services und jetzt startet chrome
einfach so na gut also ich muss sagen das rom ist schon ganz schön langsam
ich habe auf meinen anderen tablets auch ein custom rom drauf aber das ist
schneller kommt mir zumindest so vor das ist aber ein bisschen ältere android
version vielleicht ist die besser optimiert da drauf
allen speed test kannst du komplett knicken komplett alter ist das langsam
mann das kannst du komplett vergessen mann das ist nicht benutzbar nicht
benutzbar langsamer ok vielleicht ist deswegen auch die anfahrt zeit hier so
lahm gucken wir mal ich gucke mal kurz ob ich mein home assistant hier auf machen
kann also wenn das so langsam ist ganz im ernst dann dann bringt mir das nicht
viel
wie geht hier mein home assistant auf zeigt mal kurz eins drei zwei hier ob
dass ich überhaupt bedienen lässt punkt zwei punkt doppelt punkt das eins zwei
drei
nicht hatte tps alter
hatte tps wo kommen wir denn dahin ok also das funktioniert schon mal
atmen aber das ist sehr also die bedienung ohne scheiß leute die ist ultra
laggy weiß nicht ob ich das so verwenden kann oder doch doch wieder die
ältere rom verwenden muss das ist wirklich mega mega lang guck mal ich
versuche ich das mal kurz zu zeigen schaut mal
guck mal wenn ich hier rüber switche guck mal seht ihr so seht ihr das ich
switch jetzt mal rüber seht ihr wie das lag beim rüber switchen
und wie die sachen nacheinander aufploppen das kannst du das kannst du
mal komplett vergessen also das ist nicht nutzbar
und sowas liegt bestimmt auch nicht an fehlenden kugelservice oder sonst was
sondern es ist einfach lahm af welches android das ist ich denke 9 hätte ich
jetzt mal vermutet
guck mal baut tablet 9 ist das 9
nie ein ipad ist dafür unsinnig für das was ich vor habe
das ist hyper laggy der browser das ist auf dem anderen tablet nicht der fall
das ist auf jeden fall nicht nicht gut was man man sieht es ja irgendwie auch
schon das ist denn der neueste rom ja man sieht es ja auch schon guck mal
ernsthaft wenn ich hier pinge und es liegt neben
am access point alle was ist das mein anderes tablet hat ich ich zeige ich
bin mal ich bin mal pingen mal kurz das andere tablet an
der cp server wir müssen das andere wieder flaschen ließes feier 12 ja 14 14
ist das andere guck mal das ist das andere ok
das scheint ein etwas inkonsistentes wifi zu haben
aber das andere läuft umlängen besser
also auf dem anderen tablet habe ich dieses rom drauf hier guck mal also
das ist das was wir jetzt hier gerade installiert habe ich dachte mir ich
mache mal was neueres also auf dem anderen habe ich das da drauf
nichts der rom unterscheidet das gucken wo das andere überhaupt ist
das da habe ich da glaube ich drauf auf dem anderen
ne 14 14 habe ich drauf 14.1 habe ich auf dem anderen drauf
und es läuft deutlich besser
also es ist auf jeden fall viel viel flüssiger als damit
kann es daran liegen dass ich keine google service das habe eigentlich nicht
es ist doch vollkommen egal weil ich habe sogar den web view aktualisiert
das ist einfach lahm
ja ich glaube ich glaube das ist einfach das ist zu zu neu für das tablet
wo der speedtest ist so mega langsam das kannst du gar kannst du keinem zeigen das ist unbenutzbar
die ganze speedtest seite leckt beim speedtest machen
oder kommt auf 40 mbit ne da deckt der ganze browser ist langsam und und laggy
gibt es einen coolen browser benchmark das kannst du nicht verwenden das ist
komplett unbenutzbar ich überlege ob ich noch das andere flash jetzt
wie kriege ich jetzt den anderen rom drauf ich bin mir gar nicht sicher ob ich den rom
drauf habe oder sogar noch das 12.1
kann ich nicht einfach die downloaden jetzt und dann in das boot menü gehen und die direkt
flashen also ich downloade den kram jetzt einfach vom tablet und dann gehe ich in
tvrp und und flash das das ist doch wahrscheinlich am einfachsten da mache ich das doch jetzt
mal mal gucken wie mal gucken pass mal auf pass mal auf wie lahm der download jetzt ist
download alter android file host was ist das für eine komische seite will
ich da überhaupt irgendwas runterladen monka es da bin ich da auf welcher scam seite bin
ich da jetzt keine ahnung ok hier 14 14.1 unofficial es gibt noch einen 14.1 oder
click here to start download ja start auf gib ihm oh gut dass ich nicht gezeigt ne passt
schon ich wollte grad sagen gut dass ich nicht gezeigt habe ich dachte es gibt tos tos werbung
aber es war keine tos werbung es sah nur so aus aber ich hab schiss dass es tos werbung
gibt deswegen zeige ich euch jetzt nicht so download what file downloaded monka es alter
ja ok jetzt download oder elf minuten mann guckt mal wie langsam ein wifi ist guckt euch
das an elf minuten für 363 mb und das wird mega heiß hinten ach du scheiße mann ok
der romp funktioniert nicht richtig das kannst du vergessen ich glaube ich na ok ne passt
der ist schon der ist schon mal 40 mb passt jetzt mal eine andere frage chat wie komme
ich denn jetzt überhaupt wieder in dieses bootmenü rein von eben muss ich jetzt irgendwie
knöpfe gedrückt halten ich hab direkt einen ich hab doch den direkten vergleich zwischen
dem gleichen tablet mit nem anderen rom und dem hier rund volume down und pow also ich
schalte aus also ich fahr das ding runter und dann drücke ich volume down und schalte
ein oder ich glaube im rebootmenü kann man einfach recovery auswählen ok das probieren
wir gleich aus das probieren wir gleich aus ok wir haben schon haben schon ein bisschen
was ok das download ist das download ist wirklich abverklangsam sekunde wir laden das jetzt
noch mal hier runter ich mein leute guck mal der hier ist neuer obwohl was ist denn das
für nen android android version was ist das für ne wo sieht man das steht das da dabei
was das für ne android version ist 5 ja android 5 ist glaube ich sogar sinnvoll android 5
zunehmend wisst ihr warum weil das tablet wird ja eigentlich auch mit android 5 ausgeliefert
das ist halt uralt ich glaube ohne scheiße ich glaube ich hab diesen rom auf dem anderen
drauf das hau ich da jetzt das hau ich jetzt einfach auch drauf ich hoffe es kommt keine
toss werbung 2000 hier download was ist denn da das neueste hier das da download gib ihm
das ist fürs feier hdc 2005 was ne ist es nicht erzählt doch nichts chat wait a minute
ich glaube das ist einfach nur blödsinn was da steht oder ne das ist das ist blödsinn
was da steht ich glaube das ist 2017 aber das hier ist das richtige das ist das richtige
was hier verlinkt ist aber jetzt flutscht hier 2017 ist das
ok also copy copy rom to your device flash rom gut dann rebooten wir jetzt mal würde
ich sagen ich bin übrigens blöde warum lade ich das denn hier runter keck copy download
link hier muss ich das runterladen ok dann dann schließe ich das jetzt nämlich mal ans
abbrechen dann schließen wir das nämlich jetzt mal wieder an raspberry pi an und jetzt
gucken wir mal also chat mal gucken ob das funktioniert rebooten ne geht nicht also nur
mal dass ich jetzt richtig verstehe ich mach jetzt power off ich mach power off und dann
drücke ich volume was was volume up oder volume down du musst das erweiterte reboot
menü ok wo wo ist das sekunde system settings erweitertes reboot pfeiffer time was man hier
alles finde ich nichts zu in den settings wie heißt denn das extended reboot menü android
system gesten und bewegung monka es system advanced gesten und bewegung ne da steht nix
das redde wäre ja auch echt weird champ oder keine ahnung wo das ist ok ich schalte es
jetzt aus so power off so power off und jetzt plus und power button halten power plus volume
down ok auf gehts power und volume down ja geiler amazon knopf alter was was davon ist
denn jetzt volume down und ab da steht nix drauf ich denke einfach mal das linke dürfte
volume down sein ok jetzt ist das logo erschienen und jetzt war wahrscheinlich der falsche knopf
achso was fastboot ne ich will recovery volume down plus power ist richtig
näher am rand ist volume up ernsthaft ich probiere das jetzt einfach aus ok ok also
chat hier das da ich hab es raus gekriegt das da ist volume up und das da ist also
das linke ist volume down ok also ich will wahrscheinlich recovery also will ich power
down plus das hab ich gerade gehalten ok also moment ich will ich will power down und power
down ja ok ok ok ok so ich halte es jetzt gedrückt beides massive und nun
Dann warten bis das Menü kommt bei Hold Da steht jetzt Amazon da, ich hold die jetzt
weiter. Nö, das klappt nicht. Es bootet wieder. Wisst ihr was ich jetzt mache? Kann ich nicht
einfach wieder ins Android Debug in ADB gehen und Step 1 ausführen? Wo hat das denn jetzt
downgeloaded? So ich mach jetzt erst mal ADB an wieder. Ich muss wieder ein Developer werden,
Hacker-Man Zeug hier. Bäm. Wo sind denn die Developer-Settings jetzt? Die?
Developer-Options, da sinds doch. So und jetzt ADB, Android Debugging aktivieren. Ok, alles
klar. Also und jetzt ADB, ADB Reboot, Recovery. Oh, oh, oh. Also wenn das jetzt
klappt ist das ja mit Abstand das einfachste, da musst du dir nicht merken welche Knöpfe
du für was drückst. Ne, das ist wieder Amazon am Start. Aha, jetzt erzählt er da unten
aber irgendwas von Recovery Mode. Aha, exellent. Sehr schön. So wie ging das jetzt? Side-Load?
Sagt mir wenn ich irgendwie komische Sachen mache. Kackel2.zip. Ja. Erst Vibe, dann Flaschen.
Ok Vibe. Diesen Standard Vibe hier Leute. Guck mal. Diesen Default Vibe machen. Einfach
jetzt wippen und gut ist. Oder mehr. Swipe Factory Reset. Der reicht, alles klar. Dann
swipe ich jetzt mal. Ok. Halt mit. Jetzt. Ach das wars. Das geht aber ganz schön schnell.
So. Und jetzt. Side-Load. Kackel2.zip. Bam. Ne, was muss ich dazu machen? Da muss ich
erstmal Advanced Side-Load anklicken. Aha. Ich lerne das ja. Ok. Kackel2 wird geflasht.
Ich hoffe jetzt, dass es nicht wieder kaputt geht. Guck mal. Allein schon das Flaschen
geht schneller als das letzte Mal. Ja gut das ROM wird ja auch kleiner sein. Gucken
wir mal. Die ROMs sind ja wahrscheinlich einfach auch kleiner. Das ist 5. Das ist. Ja guck
mal. Das ist halt 150 MB kleiner. Hatte hier schon wer eine Custom ROM gebaut? Also ich
nicht. Habe ich auch ehrlich gesagt nicht vor. Was schreiben die Leute eigentlich in
diesem anderen Thread zu Performance? Also wie gesagt bei mir war das mega langsam alles.
Da muss man da noch mehr machen. Overheating Issue. Ja ich will kein Overheating Issue
haben. Da bin ich nicht so scharf drauf. Ich will das Tablet an der Wand hängen lassen
und dann ist gut. So jetzt haben wir es geschafft. Und jetzt. Alter. Back. Und jetzt ADB Reboot.
So ich ziehe mal kurz hier ab. Man weiß ja nie. Jetzt sollte der starten. Hoffe ich
mal wieder ganz normal. Und jetzt den ROM halbwegs bedienbar haben. Äh das ROM bzw.
das OS halt. Guck mal hier. Der Start geht auch schon viel schneller. Ich hoffe. Ah
ich muss wieder WLAN Passwort eingeben. Ok. Schauen wir mal. Also das müsste jetzt exakt
das gleiche sein was ich auf den anderen Tablets auch drauf habe. Eigentlich wollte ich heute
mal das neuere ausprobieren. Kannst du mal schauen ob hier WLAN per QR Code einrichten
geht. Ja ich zeige natürlich jetzt mein WLAN QR Code meine Kamera. Android ist starting.
Ich habe aber gar kein QR Code zur Hand für mein WLAN. Da müsste ich jetzt ein neues
Gerät anlegen bei mir in den Settings. So jetzt machen wir erstmal WLAN gleich wenn
das gestartet ist. Ist schon gestartet. Pog. Next. Ja das ist gleich viel viel schneller.
Und er macht komischen Sound. Ich hoffe ich habe mich nicht vertippt.
Obtaining IP Address. Nice. Hat funktioniert. Next. Next. Next. Zeitzone. Ja. Ok. Ok. Ok.
Berlin. Next. Start. Yeah. Got it. Ok Leute wir sind back. Und jetzt bin ich mal gespannt
ob es jetzt besser funktioniert. Ich will jetzt nicht die Kamera starten. Lul. Du du
du du du du du. Ich habe da kein Browser drauf kann das sein. Standardmäßig. Kann
das sein dass da standardmäßig kein Browser drauf ist. Doch. Was zum. Alter Leute was
ist denn das. Moment das. Wartet mal. Was zum. Ok. Was ist. Was ist das für ein Browser
Alter. Startpage. Was. Privacy Mode. Ich weiß gar nicht was der von mir will. Ok.
Und ich bin verwirrt. Wo ist mein Download überhaupt.
Das APK ist noch da. Ok das ist gut. Kann ich F-Droid gleich nochmal installieren.
Settings. Startpage wurde als Google ohne Tracking gedacht. Aber was ist das für ein
komischer Browser. Na vielleicht war das ja mal Default. Kann ja sein. Ok jetzt muss
Odroid wieder 3 Stunden refreshen. Ne nicht Odroid. F-Droid. Odroid ist der Raspberry
Pi Konkurrent. Wie DuckDuckGo. Wobei DuckDuckGo ist ja immer noch gut oder. Oder ist DuckDuckGo
auch mittlerweile. China Chinesen Kram. Oder wie ist das. Ich hoffe nicht. Ich verwende
DuckDuckGo nämlich eigentlich. Eigentlich ganz gern. Wir haben was mit Microsoft. Ok
das ist mir neu. Das nennt sich Privacy Browser. Aha. Kommt fliegt gleich weg. So ich hau den
Aurora Store jetzt wieder drauf. Und dann. Update ich den System View. Ja Leute ohne Scheiß
das ist so viel schneller lässt sich das ganze schon bedienen gerade. Ist echt der Wahnsinn.
Es geht einfach. Next. Next. Next. Finish. So Webview aktualisieren.
Webview aktualisieren. Und richtigen Browser installieren. Also. Schauen wir mal. Was brauchen
wir denn. Pass auf hier. Leak. Leak irgendwo hier. Wir brauchen den Webview. Ich hoffe man
erkennt irgendwas. Android System Webview. Und dann. Mein Kiosk Browser und in Chrome
mach ich auch mal drauf. Man weiß ja nie. Och was will er installen. Jawoll natürlich.
Ich erlaub alles. Oh Leak kommt mal da. Leute hier. Irgendwas sieht man da von mir. Ich
weiß nicht genau was man da von mir sieht aber. Irgendwas sieht man da. Bromium. Ehrlich
gesagt. Will ich den Chrome. Brauche ich den Chrome gar nicht. Ich wollte den Chrome
jetzt eigentlich nur mal installieren. Damit ich einen Speedtest machen kann zum Vergleich.
Install. Und dann kommt eh mal ein Kiosk Browser drauf wo ich dann mein Homo System im Fullscreen
hab. Fullscreen hab und fertig. Mein Kopf. Ach mein Kopfhörer ist das hier. Das ist
mein. Mein Head. Mein Three Head ist das. Installing. Yes alles installieren. Next.
Kinder. Bulli. Search. Das da. Install. Dann haben wir alles drauf mehr brauch ich nicht.
Mit KI-Gesicht rekonstruiert Pog, lad es mal auf GitHub hoch, wie du das gemacht hast,
das wollen wir alle sehen, glaube ich, dann kann Chainlaw irgendwelche Emotes daraus
bauen.
So ich mach mal kurz nen Speedtest, wir machen vorher noch mal ne andere Sache, wir pingen
das Ding jetzt nochmal, ping, warte mal das ist, naja, die Dinger haben wohl sehr durchwachsendes
W-Lad, aber scheiß drauf, scheiß drauf.
Erstmal die ganzen Sachen auf den Startbildschirm kleben, so ich mach mal schnell nen Speedtest,
nochmal so zum Vergleich jetzt, ähm, das ist speedtest.net, nicht speedtest.org,
ja, ich kann mir das immer nicht merken, so Speedtest, accept, ja, ist schonmal deutlich
schnell, ich mein, es ist immer noch laggy as fuck, ja, aber die Webseite funktioniert
wenigstens halbwegs, ok, es ist immer noch langsam, aber es läuft besser, da bin ich
ja schonmal ganz froh drüber, ok, nice, dann hätten wir das, dann können wir jetzt eigentlich
mit der Home Assistant Integration weitermachen, beziehungsweise wir können, das was ich euch
zeigen wollte, weil ich hab jetzt alles drauf, was ich brauche.
Ich mach jetzt Home Assistant nochmal schnell auf, ähm, und zwar, Doppelpunkt, Doppelslash,
das war das 192.168.2.132.8123, meine Güte, was man sich ja alles merken muss, ok, Kunst,
ja, das ist viel schneller, ich versteh zwar nicht so genau, warum, ich mein, ne neuere
Android Version sollte jetzt ja eigentlich nicht so krass viel langsamer sein, ja, guckt
jetzt, ich kann euch mal im Vergleich zeigen hier, das gleiche was wir vorher gemacht haben,
hier rumswitchen, guckt, der switcht jetzt, der switcht jetzt gleich, habt ihr das gesehen,
zack zack, ist das umgeschaltet, so jetzt können wir nämlich mal die neue Integration
ausprobieren, die ist wirklich nice, man kann nämlich das komplette Tablet jetzt fernsteuern
damit über Home Assistant, integrations, add, huli, host 122.168.1, äh, was war meine jetzt,
war das jetzt die 14 oder die 12, MonkaS, äh, die, die 12, 112, Passwort, 1234, Standard,
weiß nicht, na, fail to connect, na super, äh, muss ich jetzt vielleicht noch starten,
muss man das noch irgendwie starten hier, get a plus license, naja, ich will den Demo
Modus ausprobieren, ah, remote administration, enable remote administration, glaub das muss
man, muss man machen, hm, remote Passwort, Massive Passwort, 1234, kommt keiner drauf,
nee komm, komm wir sind secure, Leute wir sind secure, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, ich glaub jetzt
kann nix mehr passieren, ich glaub jetzt haben wir's, jetzt ist safe, jetzt sind, jetzt sind
wir safe, Activate, alles Activate, alles, alles Activate, was, warum soll ich noch mal
neu einloggen, Admin, ach jetzt hab ich da ein Watermark drüber oder was, weil ich plus
features aktiviert hab, ja das machte ich, ich hab ja sogar eine Lizenz noch für 2,5,
für ein zusätzliches Tablet, mal kurz so platzieren, dass man dank dem Licht nix sieht, so und jetzt
kann ich's hinzufügen, 112, 123, 4, 5, 6, Submit, aha, du du du du du, du bist Michael
5 Spillian, moin, alter Account, ja, was, was schreibt er, hallo Max, hab heute mit einer
Mädel geflirtet, nicht fett, warum nicht, egal, nicht fett und die kennt mich, konnte
damit ein, dass ich meinen eigenen Emote auf deinem Channel haben könnte, dank, das ist
doch Chebat, oder, das ist doch Chebat, das glaube ich dir nett, das ist doch, das ist
kein Chebat, nice, dann freut es mich, dass ich dir helfen konnte, indirekt, irgendwie
konnte ich dir anscheinend helfen, wenn du sie noch mehr beeindrucken willst, kann ich
dir auch einen Clip aufnehmen, wo ich irgendwie was sage, dann bist du, dann ist aber die
Sache gesichert, ja, ok, also wo sind wir jetzt stehen geblieben, ich will ja mal nicht
so sein, ok, also guck mal, wir konnten jetzt, es gibt jetzt eine neue Integration für diese,
diese App, ich hoffe man sieht das gescheit, eigentlich müsste ich es halt mal irgendwie
hier hinlegen, aber dann leuchtet es zu sehr, aber passt mal auf, was man jetzt machen kann,
über Home Assistant, wenn man diese neue Integration verwendet, die weiß, guck mal,
man kann total viel einstellen jetzt, auf diesem Tablet, ich kann Restart Browser machen zum
Beispiel, bam, Restart der Browser, habt ihr gesehen, direkt aus Home Assistant, Fernsteuern,
ich kann sagen Screen, was ist das, Screen Brightness kann ich sagen, irgendwo, hier
Screen Brightness, oh, jetzt ist es weg, weil der Browser sich gerade neu gestartet hat,
weg, das ist natürlich super, das ist natürlich äußerst High IQ, den Browser, ok, jetzt rediscovert
er das wieder, alles klar, guck mal, ich kann die Screen Brightness einstellen, oh, was,
not a number, warum nicht, guckt, seht ihr, ich kann jetzt über Home Assistant die Screen
Brightness einstellen von dem Gerät, was ziemlich nice ist, stopp, das hier ist, das
ist bugged, guck mal, das ist bugged, man kann den Screen Safer anmachen, was nichts
bringt, weil, ich glaube, ich habe gar keinen Screen Safer da drauf, da geht einfach der
Bildschirm aus, wenn ich den Screen Safer anmache, Screen Safer aus, Screen an, Screen
aus, wenn du das echt machen könntest, wäre das immer einfach sagen, hallo der Michael
voll nett und Grüße an die Lisa, ja mache ich, hallo der Michael voll nett und Grüße
an die Lisa und jetzt, ganz wichtig, weeps in, wenn es dir hilft, passt doch, lull, stellt
euch mal vor, es bringt jetzt wirklich was, dann freue ich mich für ihn, gleich, gleich
die Überholspur genommen, hier bei Lisa, wie es aussieht, der Michael, direkt erstes
Kind, genau, das jetzt flutscht, ja das wollte ich euch zeigen, das erste Kind muss dann
einmal Max heißen, das ist aber wirklich das Mindeste, wo bin ich jetzt stehen geblieben,
keine Ahnung, aber das wollte ich euch zeigen, es ist doch wirklich nice, dass man hier,
man kann es übrigens sogar als Media Player verwenden von Home Assistant aus, man kann
daraufhin irgendwelche Töne abspielen und sowas und der Chat kommt auf die Hochzeit,
genau, seht ihr aber es ist wirklich cool oder, dass man das Tablet jetzt quasi komplett über
Home Assistant steuern kann und meine, also was ich mit diesen Tablets mache ist folgendes,
ich habe ein extra Dashboard nur für Tablets, so und dort habe ich dann so Sachen drauf
wie, also ich jetzt Autoladestand, Fenster und Türen geschlossen und sowas, so die wichtigsten
Sachen, das hängt im Flur und nachts, wenn es Nacht wird, mache ich dann zum Beispiel
da drüber halt auch, über diese Fernsteuerung mache ich den Display dunkler, man könnte
theoretisch den Screen auch komplett abschalten, ja und man kann sogar Urls switchen da drüber,
Map leaked, OMG, Map leaked Leute, oh nein, man kann sogar die Startuhr laden lassen,
guck dann lädt er die Seite neu, wo ich mir nicht ganz sicher bin, ist ob ich eine Custom
Url laden kann, was ist das hier, Screen Safer Time, guck mal du siehst, du siehst die Batteriestand,
du siehst die aktuelle Seite und solche Sachen, ist wirklich nice, achja man kann die Screen
Orientation glaube ich auch irgendwie umschalten, die Integration gibt es erst seit glaube ich
dem letzten oder vorletzten Home Assistant Update, also ist wirklich ziemlich neu und
finde ich aber in Kombination halt wirklich nice, Cloudless Voice Assistant gibt es ein
paar Funktionen aber ich verwende keine Voice Assistant, deswegen kenne ich mich in dem
Bereich nicht aus, die Preis ist für die Hardware ist für den Preis mehr als ok, du
kaufst hier diese Dinge am besten, wenn irgendein Amazon Prime Day Weihnachts Special oder sowas
ist, ich habe die damals glaube ich für 80 oder 85 Euro gekriegt, normalerweise kosten
die unter 90 Euro, normalerweise kosten die glaube ich 145, was kostet ein aktuelles
Firehalle, 150 ja, mit und ohne Werbung, das ist blödsinnig, ohne Werbung kannst du dir
sparen, du musst halt mal gucken ob man die neueren flaschen kann, wobei das nicht wirklich
notwendig ist, ich weiß nicht ob man die neuen flaschen kann, die neuen sind von wann, 2021
glaube ich, schauen wir mal, ja die 2001, das habe ich auch, das haben wir heute geflasht
und geroutet, Suez, Suez habe ich auch, Suez, guck da, wobei ich den alten rum genommen
und das alte rum genommen habe, weil das neue nicht richtig gelaufen ist, weiß gar nicht
ob die 2000, guck mal die ganz neuen sind anscheinend auch schon zu flaschen, ok dann
ist es eigentlich fast egal, kannst ja alles kaufen, anscheinend kann man das flaschen,
das ist natürlich nice, ich muss mal kurz schauen ob man hiermit jetzt tatsächlich auch
die URL switchen kann auf dem Tablet, mal kurz gucken, also noch ist ja hier die Startseite,
kann ich jetzt sowas machen wie hier Developer Tools, Services, Pulli, nee, weiß gar nicht
wie man das aufruft, anscheinend, nee anscheinend gibt es da keine, anscheinend kann man da
nicht die URL switchen, man kann nur zurück switchen auf die Startseite, Device plugged
in, Battery following controls are available, nee gibt keine Services, Load start URL kann
man nur machen, also ich kann bloß sagen, wo ist hier die Fully, Fully integration,
ja also ich kann bloß sagen Load start URL, Send to background und dann, ah da bin ich
im Hauptmenü, nee gut das bringt mir jetzt nicht so alt so viel, Bring to foreground
start URL, ist aber schon nice, tja und jetzt muss man es halt so machen, so werde ich für
dieses Tablet auch einrichten und so habe ich es für die anderen Tablets auch eingerichtet,
kann ich euch eigentlich zeigen, ich kann es euch zeigen, weil das ist wirklich ein echt
cooles Feature, also ich habe folgendes eingestellt, ich habe mir ein extra Dashboard gemacht,
nur für die Tablets, ein Dashboard mit so den wichtigsten Sachen und ein Dashboard
mit Kameras drauf, Kameras kann ich euch jetzt natürlich nicht zeigen, außer ich baue mal
eine Fake-Kamera ein, könnten ihr eine Fake-Kamera einbauen, dass ich es euch zeigen kann, zumindest
habe ich es so gemacht, wenn es an der Tür klingelt, dann switcht das Tablet automatisch
auf den Kameratab für 30 Sekunden, aber instant, switcht das um und nach 30 Sekunden geht es
wieder aufs Dashboard zurück, sodass du quasi sofort gucken kannst, weil direkt daneben
hängt die Türgegensprechanlage, wenn du dran gehst, kannst du direkt drauf gucken,
wer ist das, sage ich, oh nee das ist wieder der Typ, der uns Zeug verkaufen will, dann
gehe ich gar nicht erst ran, das ist halt enorm praktisch, das geht alleine mit Fully allerdings
nicht so schön, ich könnte als Start-Uhr die Seite mit den Kameras einstellen und dann
kann ich in den Settings einstellen, dass der umschalten soll auf eine andere Seite,
nach so und so vielen Sekunden wieder, das ist aber nicht so schön, muss ich sagen, es
ist auch langsam, weil er die Seite immer neu lädt, viel besser ist es, wenn man den
Home Assistant selbst fernsteuern kann auf dem Tablet und dazu gibt es ein eigenes Add-on,
nennt sich Browser-Mod, ich zeige es euch einfach, wir haben doch Zeit, gibt es den
Home Assistant Browser-Mod und darauf kann man dann nicht nur den Browser fernsteuern
mit Fully, sondern komplett die gesamte Seite vom Inhalt her auf, also von Klicken auf
der Seite, ich muss aber erstmal den Home Assistant Community Store installieren, sonst
wird das nix, Settings, Integrations, haben wir hier Hux, wo ist es denn, Hux, kann man
nicht installieren, muss ich noch installieren, mal kurz ein bisschen kleiner, dann zeige
ich euch wie das geht, ich brauch mal irgendeine Fake-Kamera, hat jemand irgendeine gute Webseite
mit irgendwelchen Streams, wo man mal was einbinden kann, Manhattan-Webcam, ja perfekt,
wenn die irgendwie eine gescheite, wenn die mal, die hat ja kein RTSP-Stream oder so,
kann man jetzt einfach die JPEG-Uhrl rechts klicken und dann update das öfters mal, naja,
müssen wir mal ausprobieren, erstmal muss ich den Home Assistant Community Store installieren,
mach ich, mach ich, was, Generic-Camera, gibt das irgendwo, oder was anderes, ok, Camera,
MJPEG-IP-Cam, Live-Kamera, ja, nee, nee, das geht so nicht, YouTube geht glaub ich
noch nicht, das wär natürlich geil, oder, wenn du mittlerweile direkt YouTube-Streams
in Home Assistant nennst, nee, nee, YouTube-Streams gehen glaub ich nicht, das ist RTSP-Gedulds,
ATTP, ich mein, wisst ihr was, ich probier's einfach mal, Streaming-Uhrl, mach gucken,
glaub nicht, dass das funktionieren wird, mach gucken, mach gucken, ich seh nicht so
aus, als würde das funktionieren, welche Kameras kannst du empfehlen, ich hab auch
zum größten Teil Reolinks, und naja, für den Preis sind die unschlagbar, aber, sag
ich mal, so, nee, sondern nicht geil, hatte ich hier nicht letztens den RTSP-Test, Admin
Q-Chat, nee, Big Buck Bunny Moff, genau, das brauchen wir, oh, das gibt's nicht mehr,
aber, oh shit, ja, aber das ging, das hab ich doch grad, probiert abzuspielen, ah, nice,
sehr schön, dann nehmen wir doch das, RTSP-TCP-Transport, was hat das mit, created configuration, nice,
da ist die Kamera, Entity, zeig mal das Bild her, ob das jetzt funktioniert, kurz mal
kurz checken, ich hab noch, ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wie man normale Kameras überhaupt
einbindet in Home Assistant, ich mach das alles über RTSP, RTSP-Stream, Image, nee,
wie geht das überhaupt, Picture, oder einfach nur Entity, Media, nee, Kamera, nee, ähm,
das war glaub ich Image, oder, Picture, nee, meine Güte, schwer kann das doch nicht sein,
Picture, Picture Entity, die Cleanse-Card war das, das wird's gewesen sein, nee, Picture
Cleanse, genau, Kamera, da funktioniert ja Exquisite, gut, ey, es funktioniert, naja,
was ist denn der Unterschied zwischen Auto und Live, Live, Live funktioniert einfach,
okay, nice, done, ich bin mir jetzt nicht sicher, das ist jetzt noch kein WebRTC, ne,
WebRTC ging ja nämlich nur mit dem Zusatzaddon, was ist denn das jetzt, Network, ah, das
ist Streaming, das ist HLS, okay, das ist auch okay, das sieht, das läuft zumindest
flüssig, also ich hab's mit dem WebRTC addon, dann ist die Kamera quasi fast Echtzeit und
super, super schnell, aber das passt, so, das können wir jetzt hier testweise nehmen,
alles klar, so, und jetzt zeige ich euch mal das mit dem, das, zeige ich euch mal, wie
ich das auf dem Tablet bei mir mache, also als erstes muss man ein neues Dashboard hinzufügen,
probieren wir mal die Kamera, das brauche ich, so, also wir brauchen ein neues Dashboard,
das ist ein bisschen versteckt, Manage Dashboards, Add Dashboard, Titel, Tablet, View Insightbar,
ja, okay, können wir jetzt machen, Icon, Tablet, Placing the Fast, ne, das geht nur, weil es
Written in Rust wäre, Create, Open, Edit, Empty Dashboard, so und jetzt hab ich hier zwei Sachen,
ich habe Kamera, ein Kamera und ein normales Dashboard, so, in dem Kameradashboard hab ich
dann ja quasi meinen ganzen Kempel hier drin, ich mach jetzt mal nur quasi exemplarisch
eine Kamera rein, man kann auch hier zum Beispiel sagen, man möchte das quasi immer im Fullscreen
haben oder, was auch immer, das hab ich noch nie ausprobiert, ja, oder so, in der Mitte,
auf dem Tablet ist so wahrscheinlich am besten, alles klar, so, jetzt muss ich erstmal kurz
gucken, wie ich auf die, hier, diese Uhr brauche ich jetzt, Loveless Tablet 0 und 1, so kann man
umschalten zwischen den URLs gleich, so, hier machen wir jetzt irgendwie mal was anderes rein,
irgendwie was so, Wohnzimmer TV, exellent, genau, das wollte ich schon immer haben, so und jetzt
muss ich den gleich, jetzt muss ich dieses Dashboard einrichten auf dem Tablet, also
hiermit starten wir und so, dass ich es umschalten kann, also dann gehen wir mal hier rein in die
Settings, sagen wir hier Settings, Startuhrl, so und da wollen wir jetzt als Startuhrl haben,
müssen wir abgucken, ich kopiere es mal auf die andere Seite, Loveless, Lovelace, Minus, Tablet,
Slash, äh, 1, ok, yes, so, jetzt sind wir schon mal auf dem richtigen Dashboard, guckt und jetzt
will ich, dass sobald es klingelt bei mir an der Tür, hier drauf geswitcht wird und dann nach 30
Sekunden wieder zurück, also stellt euch vor, das hier ist die Kamera von der Tür jetzt, ok, also
so sieht es vor meiner Tür aus, Standard Dashboard ist das hier, weil man das im Flur eben hängen
hat, so dass es die wichtigsten Sachen anzeigt, wir können es ja auch mal ein bisschen, ja hier,
sehr gut, das will ich jetzt alles haben, dann sieht das ein bisschen, da sieht es ein bisschen
gefüllter aus, ok, hör mal das Tablet, so, jetzt ist jetzt ein bisschen was los auf dem Dashboard,
so, Refresh, jetzt sieht es ein bisschen nach Dashboard aus hier, Handleak, OMFG, die Hand ist
geleakt, Kek, es gibt kein Kek-Icon, das ist aber schwach, kein Kek-Icon, so und jetzt muss ich
erstmal den Home Assistant Community Store installieren, weil ansonsten kann ich nichts
gescheites installen, keine weiteren Addons gescheiten sehen oder ja doch geht, aber ganz
im Ernst, das will man eigentlich nicht, OS Supervised, Go to the Addon Store, Install SSH
Addon, alles klar, machen wir, also, das muss man nur einmal machen und das hat man normalerweise
auch gemacht, weil ich habe das SSH Addon drauf, weil niemand betreibt sein Home Assistant ohne
aktivierte, ohne SSH Addon und ohne Hacks, das braucht man, weil darüber, werdet ihr gleich sehen,
kann man weitere Sachen nachinstallieren, ok, also 1, 3, 2, ne, was war das Root Add, Root Add,
oh, aber da, was habe ich denn da für ein riesen Ding, gleich als Root drauf, bam, so,
jetzt bin ich auf meinem Home Assistant drauf und jetzt machen wir das hier, wir machen,
wir machen Shell Befehle als Root nach Bashpipen, also, was soll da schon schiefgehen bei, so macht
man das, ne, das ist nicht vollständig, ich würde es dir aber empfehlen, weil so kannst du viel
einfacher Sachen nachinstallieren, so, remember to restart Home Assistant, Home Assistant,
before reconfiguring it, machen wir, wir restarten Home Assistant, restart, restart Server, bam,
oh, nicht Server, Server Restarten war nicht notwendig, er Restart, hat er jetzt, ne, ok,
der Chebade, der Restart hat gar nicht den Server, das war einfach nur massiv der Chebade,
der meint Restart Home Assistant, da steht Restart Server, die wissen selbst nicht, was wir da
hinschreiben, so und jetzt muss ich zu Integrationen gehen, Add und da kann ich jetzt Hux hinzufügen,
jaja, ist alles klar, oh fuck, ich kann euch das nicht zeigen, ich muss ja GitHub Authentifizierung
machen, das habe ich ja ganz vergessen, dass man das machen muss, deswegen habe ich das hier auch
nicht installiert, man muss ja GitHub Authentifizierung machen, shit, ja, ne, dann kann ich den Browser
Mod so installieren, das muss man machen, weil die Addons lädt davon GitHub runter und GitHub mag
das halt nicht, wenn die Leute auf ihrer Seite rumwursten und wenn du dir halt quasi das
authentifizieren lässt, dann funktioniert es, Installation Instructions, so, all copy contents
of Custom Components Browser Mod to your Custom Components, ok, machen wir, alles klar, naja,
wo ist denn das, Config, ne, Custom, Custom Components, alles klar, ok, Git, clone, dann
machen wir es dahin, so und jetzt sollen wir was hin kopieren, den unter Custom Mod, Custom
Components, Browser Mod, hier hin, ja, habe ich gemacht, ok, und jetzt muss ich wahrscheinlich
rebooten, kann ich mir vorstellen, rebooten, muss ich rebooten, Restart Home Assistant,
ja, man muss ja mittlerweile alles restarten, deswegen habe ich übrigens auch meine Fiat
Integration für das Auto als Addon gemacht und bin ganz froh, dass ich es als Addon gemacht
habe, weil Addons kann man wenigstens ordentlich neu starten oder alles 3000 mal neu laden
zu müssen, gut, Integration mittlerweile auch, aber es funktioniert manchmal nicht, ich bin
beeindruckt, wie schnell der Home Assistant hier startet, ehrlich gesagt, bei mir braucht
es immer ewig, aber da ist ja auch viel mehr drin, so, jetzt haben wir den, muss wir den
Browser Mod da jetzt noch hinzufügen, Browser Mod, jawoll, Browser Mod Configure, gut, ups,
ok, so und jetzt Trick 17, jetzt muss man einmal das hier schließen, neu starten und
dann hat man in das Sidebar Browser Mod und dort kann man dann hingehen und sagen, Register
Device im Browser Mod, genau, danach muss man den ganzen Krempel nochmal abschießen
und nochmal starten, sonst funktioniert es nicht und jetzt kann ich den hier fernsteuern,
den Browser von Home Assistant aus, guckt, jetzt gehe ich, ne, nicht auf Browser Mod,
da wollte ich jetzt nicht hin, jetzt gehe ich auf Developer Options, Services zum testen
und sag Browser Mod, Navigate und jetzt gehen wir zu diesem, jetzt sagen wir ihm, dass er
auf diese Seite umschalten soll, hier mit der Kamera, die aus irgendwelchen Gründen
nicht geht, aber wahrscheinlich weil es abgekackt ist, ist egal, ihr sehts gleich, Navigate,
da hin, ich glaube ich muss nur so machen, Choose Device, diesen Browser und jetzt pass
auf, habt ihr gesehen, er schaltet um und das geht saumäßig schnell, das heißt, ich
kann mir das jetzt mal hier Copy Pasten und machen eine Automation daraus, Automations,
Empty Automations, so Actions, also was wollen wir haben, wir wollen sagen Call Service,
Browser Mod, Navigate, da hin und dann, ja und nein, das geht mit Fully Kiosk Browser
auch, nur das Fully Kiosk Browser immer einen kompletten Seiten Reload macht, was dazu führt,
dass es alles 4-5 Sekunden länger dauert, als wenn du die Seite direkt Switchen lässt
mit dem Browser Mod, aber die Kombination mit dem Kiosk Browser ist trotzdem gut, erstens
kannst du dich da nicht doof verklicken auf dem Tablet und du kannst darüber Sachen wie
Bildschirmhelligkeit und so einstellen, also eigentlich in Kombination ist das das beste,
so und jetzt muss man sagen, Wait, also Stop für, nee nicht Stop, äh Delete, Actions,
ähm, um das besser zeigen zu können, ich gehe nochmal zurück hier auf die andere Seite
auf mein normales Dashboard, ich will jetzt eigentlich Wait, Wait, Wait for Time Pass,
sagen wir hier irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 15 Sekunden und jetzt nächste Action, wieder
auf, wieder Call Service, Navigate und jetzt gleich das Tablet und jetzt zurück auf das
zweite, Save, Tablet Switchen, was weiß ich, äh, Klingel, Tablet, oh, und jetzt kann ich
da draufklicken, also das wird jetzt getriggert, wenn ich, ich mach das mal groß, also mir
bräuchte jetzt natürlich irgendwas, wo man erkennt, dass die Haustürklingel geklingelt
hat und jetzt, dann triggert das das, so, zack, dann Switcht das um, zeigt euch das
Bild von der Haustürklingel und dann geht das automatisch hin nach 15 Sekunden und navigiert
zurück, wenn ich jetzt alles richtig gemacht hab, so, hat funktioniert, easy und man kann
das natürlich auch schön kombinieren, wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel sagt, ahja gut, ähm,
man kann das auch ganz schön kombinieren jetzt mit den anderen Sachen, zum Beispiel
könnte man sagen, ahja, ok, kann man das hier, kann man das hier irgendwie moveen, ich meine,
ich kanns im jammeln moveen, aber kann ichs hier irgendwie moveen, move up oder so, ja
und zum Beispiel, zum Beispiel kann ich dann sagen, danach, Call Service, Fully, nee, Quatsch,
nicht Call Service, Device ist das glaub ich, ach nee, Amazon Fire, Amazon Fire, so und
jetzt können wir ihm sagen, Turn, Turn Off Screen, also das ist jetzt nur ein Beispiel,
ich wills ja, ich wills ja standardmäßig anhaben, Turn Off Screen und jetzt machen
wir vorher noch was anderes, Duplicate, ich bin mir nicht sicher, wie ich das gescheit
verschieben kann, konnte man das nicht irgendwie moveen, also im Jammel, im Jammel kann man
es auf jeden Fall moveen, weil ich will jetzt eigentlich sagen, Turn Screen On, ähm, also,
ich weiß, dass man das irgendwie moveen konnte, ich glaube, ich bin da zu Pepega für, wie
ich mein, man will das ja vielleicht auch mal bewegen, ich wollte jetzt vor alles andere
dieses Turn Screen On machen, ok, Home Assistance, ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, dass man das
moveen konnte, ach, das war im letzten UI, das kann natürlich sein, aber kann ich jetzt
das ganze vielleicht noch als Jammel editieren, ok, ja, dann ist ok, dann kann ichs immer
noch machen, so, Turn On, ja, genau, so will ich das haben, ok, also, wenn man jetzt zum
Beispiel sagt, ey, Nacht soll das Tablet aus sein, aber ich will, dass es angeht, wenn
es klingelt an der Tür, dann habe ich das jetzt eingerichtet, jetzt sage ich Run, dann
geht das Tablet an, switcht auf die Kamera an der Tür, dann kannst du dir das angucken
für 30 Sekunden und dann switcht er automatisch wieder auf dein normales Dashboard und macht
das Tablet aus, da war auch Reorder, ja, das ist natürlich, für nachts ist das wirklich
nice, wenn man nachts das Tablet ausmachen will, alternativ man kann das Tablet auch
dimmen, ich hab das Tablet nachts nur gedimmt auf 1% oder so, ja und wenn es jetzt wieder
klingelt, gehts an, switcht rüber auf die Kamera und geht, das ist wirklich nice, aber
was konnte man, man konnte hier oben reordern, ach, ach, jetzt sind da, ok, ich verstehe,
normale Pfeile waren anscheinend zu bloated, ich mein, ich mein, hier ist ja offensichtlich
kein Platz mehr für so nen drag und drop Button, kannst du auch erst switchen und dann
einschalten, du meinst, dass ich zuerst switche, das geht auch, klar, kann ich auch machen,
ich kann auch, du meinst, dass man nur das eine sieht dann, dass es gleich, dass man
das umschalten gar nicht sieht, jaja, das funktioniert auch, kann auch das hier zuerst
hin machen, ja, Browser Mod, jetzt ist der Browser Mod zuerst, ne, ne, das funktioniert
nicht nur bei eingeschaltetem Display, guck, run, jetzt hat, gut, du hast es jetzt noch
kurz gesehen, du müsstest vielleicht noch ein Delay einbauen, wenn du wirklich nicht
willst, dass es das sieht, aber, ne, ne, das funktioniert auch bei ausgeschaltetem Display,
und ich hab es halt so, ich hab nicht hier Screen-on, sondern ich hab hier drinnen, wenn
es nachts ist, Brightness, kann man hier nämlich auch einstellen, man kann sagen, Set Value
Brightness auf 1 oder gar auf 0, kann man sogar sagen, save, und wenn ich das jetzt
ausführe, guck, dann, geht an, switcht rüber auf die Kamera, und nach 15 Sekunden, Display,
das Tablet bleibt die ganze Zeit an, ja, wenn das einschaltet, du kannst die Displaysperre
auch ausmachen, und jetzt nach 15 Sekunden dimmt es sich runter, guckt, so hab ich es
nachts eingestellt, das finde ich viel besser, ich will das gar nicht komplett aushaben,
ich will es einfach gedimmt haben nachts, und so finde ich das, so finde ich das nice,
so kann man das, so kann man das lassen, ja, zack, es hat geklingelt, und ihr seht jetzt
auch, wie schnell das geht mit dem umschalten, ich mach mal wieder volle, volle Pulle, die
Helligkeit, sehr nice, exellent, ja, so hab ich es eingestellt, das ist eines der Gründe,
wofür ich die Tablets verwenden will, einfach, dass man sieht, wenn es klingelt an der Tür,
wer davor steht, und dass ich die wichtigsten Sachen auf einem Blick hab, nämlich, also
bei mir, ich kann euch mein Dashboard ja mal zeigen, mein richtig echtes Dashboard fürs
Tablet, ich muss mal kurz gucken, ob ich da nicht irgendwas drauf hab, was man nicht sehen
sollte, ne, kann ich euch, kann ich euch screenshotten, ne, kann ich euch doch nicht screenshotten,
ne, geht nicht, ha, jetzt hätt ich fast leaked, Leute, fast, fast geleaked, wobei doch, ich
leake euch das mit, ich mach einfach, ähm, Kasten drüber, dann seht ihr nix, lul, also
so sieht mein Dashboard aktuell aus, was ich auf dem Tablet, Tablet hab, das ist wirklich
nur das wichtigste und ganz minimal, was man halt, was man halt braucht, ich mein, wie gesagt,
die Tablets sind jetzt auch nicht so fett, deswegen, das Tablet ist ja schon zur Hälfte
voll da damit, ja, ich seh wie voll das Auto ist, ob Fenster und Türen auf oder zu sind,
und äh, aktuell ruht sein Wetter, fertig, und hier ist der Knopf für die Kameras von,
von der Eingangstür, vom Hof und der Eingangstür, ne, brauch ich auf dem Tablet nicht, ich lasse
mir lieber noch ein bisschen Platz, dass ich was hinbauen kann, falls ich es brauch, ja,
so siehts aus, jetzt haben wir es eingerichtet und ihr seht, das funktioniert auch relativ
zackig, hier auf dem Tablet, also das Video, Auto, ah mein Gott, ich kann da tippen, Automations,
ja, das geht halt nur, weil es i3 ist, i3 ist halt äußerst Pong, was das angeht, ich
hab die Tablets dauerhaft am Strom, ja, naja, ist jetzt ja nicht so, als wird das wahnsinnig
viel verbrauchen, wo hast du jetzt den Screenshot von deinem Port Home Assistant gemacht auf
dem zweiten Desktop, auf dem zweiten Rechner hier neben, da wo ich auch die Bilder durchklicke,
ah ja, jetzt gehts wieder, ok, Millionär, das schöne daran ist, du musst kein Millionär
sein, um sowas selbst bauen zu können, guck, das läuft doch alles flüssig und hat überhaupt
keine Probleme und ich hab 1080p, Kamerastreams, also das Tablet hat schon ein bisschen was
zu tun, deswegen hab ich es lange Zeit auch probiert und Probleme gehabt, weil es ging
lange kein WebRTC da drauf, auf den Amazon Dingern, außer mit dem offiziellen StockROM,
deswegen hatte ich auf dem hier halt noch das StockROM drauf, aber jetzt ist gut, jetzt
funktioniert das auch so, ja, soll ich euch noch irgendwas zeigen, ich glaube nämlich,
das war es so im Großen und Ganzen, wir haben FlashChamp gemacht, wir haben Home Assistant
eingerichtet, man sieht das hier mit dem BrowserMod, wie nice das funktioniert, hast du Sprachsteuerung,
nee Sprachsteuerung mag ich nicht, ich hab lieber noch ein weiteres Dashboard als Sprachsteuerung,
keine Ahnung, mein neues Auto hat ja auch Sprachsteuerung standardmäßig, da kannst
du dann sagen, hey Fiat, mir ist kalt und sowas in der Richtung, verwende ich auch nicht,
ich drücke einfach den Knopf, du brauchst genau einen Knopf, um die Heizung oder die
Klimaanlage einzuschalten, also ich wüsste nicht, warum ich das über Sprachsteuerung
machen sollte, und wenn es gerade super intens ist auf der Straße, dann drücke ich halt
10 Sekunden später, Black HD, das ist keine schlechte Idee, das kann man machen, ich glaube
es sogar, die Elgato Sachen haben eine ganz gute Home Assistant Integration, guck mal
mal, Stream Deck, Home Assistant, da gibt es Custom Plugins, weil die Lichter von Elgato,
die haben eine offizielle Home Assistant Integration, habe ich euch ja schon gezeigt, also mein,
hier dieses Elgato Ring Light, was ihr hier gerade seht, das habe ich ja auch bei mir
im Home Assistant drin und dann kann ich, ich mache es mal kurz auf, so, das kann ich
hier drüber an und ausschalten und auch im Zweifelsfall die Helligkeit und so Zeug umstellen,
Farbtemperatur und sowas, hast du was mit einem selbst gehorsten Sprachsteuerung gemacht?
Nein, ich habe mal ein bisschen rumprobiert mit, was war denn das, was war das denn nochmal,
irgendein Projekt von GitHub, was dann aber von der Handhabung viel zu kompliziert war,
hast du Raspberry Pis im Haus verteilen müssen mit Mikrofon und so, ich hätte es, ich würde
ja die Sprachsteuerung vielleicht manchmal verwenden von meinem Home Assistant, wenn
ich es einfach über die App, wenn ich einfach auf Mikrofon drücken könnte und dann über
die App, aber, also aktuell ich habe wirklich keinen Anwendungszweck großartig für Sprachsteuerung.
Control your Home Assistant Devices vom Stream Deck, ja, das ist gut, dass es da Integration
für gibt.
Wo wir gerade dabei sind, wenn ihr euren Fiat, wenn ihr euren Fiat auch von Home Assistant
kontrollen wollt, könnt ihr mal einen Addon ausprobieren, wobei Commands noch nicht funktionieren,
das muss ich echt die Tage mal einbauen, aktuell kann man ja so Sachen nur abrufen.
Agila Champ, der ist zu alt, der kann sowas nicht, aber halbwegs neue Fiats können das
nicht, ich gucke jetzt nochmal in den Chat, ansonsten glaube ich war es das, mir fällt
da sonst gerade nichts ein.
Kannst du dir vorstellen, ja klar, mache ich gerne, zeige ich, also wenn ihr wollt, wir
können ruhig ab und zu mal eine Zeig mir dein Home Assistant Dashboard machen, das fände
ich sogar sehr spannend ehrlich gesagt, weil, also wenn gerade einer was hat, was er teilen
möchte mit mir und dem Chat, irgendwo hochladen auf irgendeinem Image Hoster und posten, können
wir uns jetzt auch noch ein paar Dashboards angucken, würde mich sogar echt interessieren,
weil ich immer spannend finde, was andere Leute machen und man bekommt viel Inspiration
da drüber.
Oder auf Discord, das ist eine gute Idee, wir haben doch einen Heimautomatisierungs Channel
auf Discord.
Oder über Twitter, eigentlich ist es mir egal, aber wenn wir es jetzt im Stream machen
wollen, dann wäre es gut, wenn man es jetzt postet, aber für die Zukunft, wir könnten
das tatsächlich mal sammeln und uns ab und zu ein paar Home Assistant Dashboards angucken.
Ja tatsächlich, also Black HD, wenn du dein Dashboard sharen willst, haust auf Imigur oder
sonstigem Zeug hoch und wir können uns angucken und ich gebe meinen Senf dazu.
Kannst auch einen Screenshot vom Tablet oder vom Handy machen.
Ja, ich finde da kriegt man immer recht viel Inspiration da durch, wenn man sich das anguckt,
was andere machen.
Hast du eigentlich auch Geräte, die kein WPA3 können?
Ähm ich glaube, ich habe gar keine Geräte, die WPA3 können?
Also das Ding kann auch im Leben kein WPA3.
Also ich habe glaube ich, ich weiß nicht ob ich ein Gerät habe, das überhaupt WPA3
Support hat.
Ja doch das iPhone hat wahrscheinlich WPA3 Support.
Achso, ja so habe ich das auch eingestellt, also das ist glaube ich auch Default auf
meinem Axis Point gewesen, irgendwie 3 plus 2 oder so, ja ja ja.
Ich habe da nichts rumgeschoben, ich habe mich damit noch nicht beschäftigt ehrlich
gesagt.
Ich habe jetzt alles Default gelassen.
Jo und Chat gibt es noch was, ansonsten gehe ich jetzt, ah ne ich gehe noch nichts essen,
aber bald, bald Peppofett angesagt.
Also wie es mit meinem Staubsauger Roboter aussieht, weiß ich gar nicht.
Den habe ich, den benutze ich übrigens nicht mehr, also ich habe euch ja schon ein paar
mal gezeigt, da war ich hier im Stream per SSH auf meinem Staubsauger eingeloggt, aber
den benutze ich nicht mehr, benutze aktuell keinen Staubsauger Roboter mehr.
Ich fand die Dinge an sich am Anfang wirklich sehr nice und habe mir auch eingeredet, das
bringt richtig was, so nach dem Motto losfahren und sonst was, aber ich habe halt auch noch
einen ohne selbstreinigende Station, es gibt ja mittlerweile schon richtig coole Geräte,
hast ja mittlerweile hier schon mit, mit, mit Station und sowas, ja hast ja mittlerweile
schon solche Dinger, mit selbstreinigenden Stationen und sowas, vielleicht würde ich
damit das ganze verwenden, aber es ist halt so, der Staubsauger Roboter, den kannst du
halt einstellen, dass der, also ich stelle es dir ein, dass der, dass der irgendwie um
10 oder so losfährt oder wenn du Homeoffice startest, der losfährt zu allen Räumen, das
ist ok, das Problem ist, du musst den Scheiß ja trotzdem rausräumen und ehrlich gesagt,
ich weiß nicht, du musst dann, du musst dich dann, du musst dann bücken, du musst das
Ding auf den Tisch stellen, du musst das, das, das Fach rausklipsen, dann musst du zu Mülleimer
laufen, das Fach reinleeren, dann musst du es wieder reinmachen und wieder auf die Ladestation
stellen, ganz im Ernst und das machst du dann alle zwei Reinigungsfahrten oder alle zwei
bis drei Reinigungsfahrten, also drei Reinigungsfahrten, also vier, also zwei Tage oder was auch immer,
und also das ist nervig, ganz ehrlich, ich nehme lieber einen normalen Staubsauger mittlerweile,
der hält der Beutel ewig gefühlt dagegen und dann fahre ich alle, keine Ahnung, eineinhalb
Wochen oder so mal durch, das Ding saugt besser, das saugt stärker, das kannst du viel schneller
fahren, ich meine, der Staubsauger-Roboter, der ist ja bestimmt, keine Ahnung, 40 Minuten
hier rumgegurgt oder so, bis der komplett fertig war und ich bin in, ich bin in 10 Minuten
durch, wenn überhaupt, wenn es so lange dauert, also ich bin wieder bei normalem Staubsauger
angelangt mittlerweile, tja, oh Finger leak, ne, also da, weiß nicht, bin ich nicht so
scharf drauf mehr, ich habe den Staubsauger-Roboter noch, aber der steht aktuell halt im Wohnzimmer
rum und macht nichts, okay, ja, mit der automatischen Entleerungsstation, das ist zum ersten Mal,
wo ich sage, ja, das klingt mir sinnvoll und da würde ich mir vielleicht auch einen wieder
hinstellen, ist halt die Sache, ich bräuchte halt einen ohne China-Chinesen-Cloud, weil
ich habe echt keinen Bock, dass mein Staubsauger-Roboter nur mit Cloud richtig funktioniert, ich habe
auch keinen Bock auf Staubsaugen, meine Katz hat zum Glück nicht so viel, bisschen Saugenschimmel,
okay, zeig mal her, gucken wir jetzt, komm, sehen wir mal, schauen wir nochmal was an,
ja, bei mir ist es umgedreht, ich hatte einen und ich finde, normales Saugen ist besser,
ja, okay, also, so sieht es bei mir nicht überall aus, aber schon an manchen Stellen, also meiner
hat auch eine Wischfunktion, aber ich habe die noch nie verwendet, deshalb hat er mir
das CT-Redaktionslei-Gerät Roborock S7 Max-V Ultra für ein halbes Jahr ausgeliehen, ja,
das ist der mit der Station, oder, der hat LiDAR-Sensoren, also Raummessung per Laser,
eine RGB-Kamera, kann wischen, nee, das ist der S7, ist der das mit Station, ja, ja,
also selbst mit so einer Absaugstation, ja, das ist cool, ohne Scheiß, ich glaube mit
so einer Station, da könnte ich mich auch wieder damit anfreunden, das Ding ausprobiert
und das war echt ein Härtetest, vorab eine kleine Inhaltswarnung, es wird ein paar ziemlich
eklige Bilder mit Dreck und Gammel und so geben, bleib dran, liebe Hackerinnen, liebe Internetsurfer,
liebe Hackerinnen, liebe Internetsurfer, herzlich willkommen hier bei...
Dieses Video wird gesponsert von Sophos und von Sophos kommt auch diese Botschaft, Cyberkriminelle
nehmen nicht nur...
So, erstmal ganz kurz vorab, dass ich mich bei diesem Langzeit-Test für den Roborock
S7 Max-V Ultra entschieden habe, das war eine ziemliche Zufallsentscheidung, das von Roborock...
Was heißt entschieden, ich denke, er hat einfach einen gekriegt als Leihgabe.
...Leihweise zur Verfügung gestellt, Testgerät war gerade in der CT-Redaktion und wurde dort
nicht benötigt, da habe ich mir das mal für eine Zeit nach Hause genommen.
Außerdem fand ich die Funktionen alle ziemlich interessant, vor allem die Wischfunktion...
Du brauchst doch aber China-Chinesen-Cloud, oder? Ich habe keinen Bock auf Cloud-Only-Staubsauger-Roboter.
... und die Lasermessung. Ich hatte vorher noch nie so einen Roboter in der Hand und trotzdem
lief die Ersteinrichtung absolut problemlos. Der Roboter selbst ist in diesem kleinen Karton,
da drin ist auch die einfache mitgelieferte Ladestation. Da fährt er automatisch rein
nach ein bisschen rumgerödelt.
Ja, hat meiner auch gemacht.
Aber ich habe hier ja die ultralige...
Und ich hatte es halt... Komm mal, bei mir stand das auch im Wohnzimmer an der Wand.
Und du musstest immer das Ding hochheben, auf den Tisch stellen, umdrehen, den Behälter
raus machen, den Behälter ausleeren, den Behälter wieder rein machen, wieder auf die Ladestation
stellen. Das ging mir einfach auf den Sack.
So und ich... Ich weiß nicht, vielleicht würde ich das auch verwenden mit Entladestation.
I-Load, danke für den Zap.
Ich habe hier ja die Ultra-Version und deshalb noch einen zweiten, viel größeren Karton.
Da drin ist die riesige Absaug und...
Boah, das ist aber ein Ding.
Da gibt es drei Behälter. Hier rechts ist der Staubsaugerboi drin, in der Mitte das
frische Wasser und hier links das dreckige.
Ganz schön, ganz schön. Das könnte ich dann beispielsweise gar nicht mehr ins Wohnzimmer
gescheit stellen.
Damit soll es möglich sein, dass der Roboter mehrere Wochen lang autark unterwegs ist,
ohne dass man da irgendwas ausleeren oder reinigen muss. In der von mir getesteten S7 Max-V Ultra-Variante
mit der Station...
Guckt euch mal den Namen von dem Ding an. Roborock S7 Max-V Ultra-Staubsauger-Roboter.
1400 Euro. Boah, Alter.
Der Sauger selbst kostet rund 700 Euro.
Ja, habt ihr richtig gehört.
Das ist ordentlich.
Die Station kostet genauso viel wie der Sauger selbst. Und das finde ich auch seltsam, ja.
Aber wir können uns ja erstmal anschauen, wie Sauger und Station überhaupt funktionieren.
Also hier oben in der Mitte des Saubers ist der Leider Turm, damit orientiert er sich.
Und seitlich sind eingebaut, LED-Aufhelligt, RGB-Kamera und dann noch so mechanische Sensoren.
Wisst ihr, ich mein, ja, wenn einer sagt Verschwörungstheorien so, ist er vielleicht nicht ganz, ganz falsch.
Aber ich will keinen China Cloud Roboter mit Kameras bei mir in der Wohnung haben.
Ich kann mich mit diesem Gedanken einfallen. Also erstens, ein Staubsauger-Roboter, der
cloud-mäßig funktioniert. Ok, das ist das erste, was ich nicht will. Und dann einen
mit Kameras will ich noch weniger. Und ich will eigentlich auch nicht die offizielle
App dafür verwenden, sondern ich will das ordentlich integrieren.
Gut, Home Assistant-Integration gibt es glaube ich mittlerweile über die API ganz gut. Aber
immer noch halt über die Cloud. Und ich verstehe es halt einfach nicht. Warum muss mein Staubsauger-Roboter
nach China, übers Internet nach China, damit das funktioniert?
Das hier ist die Hauptbürste. Das ist die Seitenbürste, mit der er Dreck von den Zimmerrändern
in die Hauptbürste rein manövriert. Und wenn man die Bürste rausnimmt, sieht man das Einsaugloch.
Die Saugkraft, also genauer genommen die Druckdifferenz, liegt laut Roborock bei 5100 Pascal. Zum Vergleich
bei normalen Bodenstaubsaugern mit Kabel geben die Hersteller mindestens das Doppelte an,
wenn nicht sogar das 3- oder 4-fache. Das merkt man auch. Ich habe es jetzt ja direkt
probiert. Ich habe die ganze Zeit auch oben diesen Staubsauger-Roboter rumfahren gehabt
und jetzt sauge ich wieder mit einem ganz normalen Staubsauger und es flutscht einfach
viel mehr. Hier ist das Wischtuch, das nennt sich offiziell
Vibra Rise Mob-Tuch. Also Vibra wohl wegen der Vibration. Das Tuch wird nämlich ganz
schnell mit Ultraschall hin- und herbewegt und Rise, weil es automatisch hochgezogen
werden kann, wenn der Roboter in den Teppich fährt. Die Absaugstation, also seine Roboter-Hundehütte
funktioniert so. Wenn der Roboter vom Reinigen zurückkommt, wird das Wischtuch mit Wasser
aus dem Frischwasserbehälter gespült und außerdem wird diese Bürste hier übers Tuch
gezogen und ganz zum Schluss wird es dann nochmal richtig laut. Dann saugt nämlich
die Station den Staub aus dem Sauger in diesen Staubbeutel in der Station.
Der hält erstaunlich lange. Im Test waren es dreieinhalb Monate lang, bei mindestens
drei Reinigungsdurchläufen pro Woche. Oh, das geht eigentlich. Das ist eigentlich okay.
Und seid jetzt verwirrt, weil ihr da eine Pro-Version gefunden habt, die sogar preisgünstiger
ist, nämlich mit Absaug- und Wasserstation nur 1100 statt 1400 Euro. Ja, habt ihr recht,
der ist neuer, der hat aber leider auch weniger Funktion. Von der ganzen Putzerei ist der
S7 Pro-Ultra identisch. Oh man, warum schafft es kein Hersteller, mal irgendwie ein sinnvolles
Produktbenamungszeug durchzuführen? Aber keine Kamera zur Orientierung, nur den Lasersensor.
Das wäre mir wahrscheinlich lieber. Ihr könnt nämlich in der Roborock App quasi durch
die Augen des Max-V-Ultra... Okay, das ist natürlich schon cool irgendwo....ziemlich
cool aus, oder? Und ist auch ganz schön gruselig. Das Ganze klappt übrigens auch, wenn man gar
nicht im selben W-Laden ist. Ja, und der China-Chinese guckt dann bei dir zu in der Wohnung....aus
5000 Kilometer Entfernung saugen und wischen lassen und ist als fahrbare Überwachungskamera
genutzt. Es gibt sogar einen manuellen Modus, wie so ein ferngesteuertes Auto und damit kann
man sogar Durchsagen machen. Achtung, Achtung. Achtung, liebe Äckerin, liebe Internet-Surfer.
Tolle Funktion. Achtung, Achtung. Da könnte ich meine Katze verwirren, wenn ich nicht da
bin und ich rede auf einmal. Auch ein Mikrofon eingebaut, also der Roboter überträgt auch
das, was als Antwort... Ach, dann kann man mit den Leuten sogar sprechen. Man kann quasi
telefonieren, reden über den Schaubsauger-Roboter. Im Raum dann gesprochen wird, also ziemlich
futuristisch und man kann damit ganz gut Leute erschrecken. Übrigens, diese Videofunktion
ist nicht standardmäßig eingeschaltet. Das muss man manuell aktivieren. Und wenn ihr
Angst habt, dass Roborock euch ausspioniert, das Gerät funktioniert auch ohne jegliche
Internetverbindung, zumindest im Standard-Modus. Wenn man den Knopf hier drückt, säubert es
die ganze Wohnung und fährt auch automatisch wieder ins Dock zurück. Aber mehr halt nicht.
Wenn ihr den S7 gedenkt... Ja, das ist natürlich doof. Wenn ihr die App verkoppelt, kann man
sehr viele Sachen mehr machen. Zum Beispiel die Saugleistung in 4 und die Wischintensität
in 3 Stufen einstellen. Ihr könnt No-Go-Zonen einrichten, genau festlegen, in welcher Reihenfolge
er die Zimmer abklappern soll, dass an bestimmten Stellen nur gesaugt und an anderen nur gewischt
wird usw. So, aber jetzt wirklich mal zu meinen Erfahrungen. Ich war am Anfang definitiv
positiv überrascht, dass das Ding doch einigermaßen mit meiner Wohnung klarkommt, wo nicht jeder
Zentimeter freigeräumt ist. Also Stühle, Kissen und sowas sind kein Problem. Bisschen
Spielzeug ist auch nicht schlimm. Das schiebt der Roboter aber womöglich etwas durch.
Ich wollte mal gerade was gucken. Ups, jetzt hab ich irgendwie... 748 waren wir, gell?
Ich wollte mal gerade was gucken. GitHub. Auf welchen Geräten läuft denn das aktuell?
Hatte irgendwas? Supported Devices? Supported Robots? Roborock? Nope. Die gibt es nicht
mehr. Die werden nicht mehr supported. Die neueren. Die haben wahrscheinlich einfach
keine Sicherheitslücken mehr, dass du so flaschen kannst. Ja, sind zu wenige. Sind
Prinzip nur die Dreamy-Dinger und die älteren Roborocks. Aber ich will halt ein, warum baut
denn keiner mal einen Staubsauger-Roboter mit Absaugfunk, mit Absaugstation, was gut funktioniert,
über lokal steuerbar, über sinnvolle APs, sei es ein Web-Interface, sei es MQTT, sei
es irgendwelche Rest Endpoints, was auch immer. Warum muss es immer nur diese eine App sein
und China-Chinesen klaut? Sag doch. Rechnet sich nicht, ja. Das nächste ist dann, das
nächste ist, dass die wahrscheinlich dann Funktionen mit Abo freischalten lassen und
sowas. Ich sehe es schon kommen. Du musst dann demnächst nur noch zwei Jahre wischen
inklusive. Danach brauchst du ein Abo. Bürste ist blockiert. Ja, dann könnte er jetzt Remote
steuern können und ihn rauslotsen. Nee, das geht wahrscheinlich nicht, weil der hängt
fest. Ich denke, der hängt fest und du kriegst ihn auch mit der Fernsteuerfunktion nicht
raus. Manchmal fahren die über Stuhlfüße drüber und hängen dann mit dem Reifen in
der Luft und so. Was ich für einen habe? Ich habe einen Roborock S5, glaube ich.
Der Roboter hatte vorher offenbar gecheckt, okay, wenn ich hier raus will, geht was kaputt,
habe ich nicht gecheckt. Übrigens war das Problem, dass der Roboter mit der Hauptrolle
eine Pflanze eingewickelt hatte. Genau das ist in den allermeisten Fällen das Problem.
Frieto, Dankeschön für den Sub. Der Roboter hat das Genick bricht. Alles, was Schnurband
oder Fransenartig ist, wird komplett eingewickelt. Da hatte meiner hat mit meinem Teppich im
Wohnzimmer Probleme. Das hat auch so Fransen an der Seite. Da hat er schon öfters Probleme
mit gehabt. Und dann ist halt vorbei. Dann muss ein Mensch helfen. Aus diesem Grund versucht
der Roboter Schuhe weiträumig zu umfahren. Mit seiner KI-Erkennung klappt das sogar
einigermaßen. Was noch schlimmer wäre als ein verhätteter Schnürsenkel wäre ein Haustier
Kackhaufen. Logisch, weil wenn das Teil da durchfährt, wird das halt in der ganzen Wohnung
verteilt. Die KI-Erkennung reagiert deshalb besonders sensibel auf Haustierschmutz. Nur
leider habe ich einen Teppich. Was haben die alles für Haustiere? Also meine Katzen
kacken in der Regel nicht irgendwo in die Wohnung. Wie er eingewebt hat, tja. Man kann
aber auch dann manuell in der App sagen, das ist kein Haustierschmutz. Das soll so. Und
das speichert der Roboter dann auch. Und dann wird er davon nicht mehr so aus dem Konzept
gebracht. Bisschen lustig, diese ziemlich große Holzkugel ist laut. Haustierschmutz.
Na ja. Was soll das bitte für ein Haustier sein? Ein kürrendes Haustrecks. Naja, gewisserweise
ist es schwierig jetzt zu unterscheiden, oder? Was man aber ganz klar sagen muss, solche
unruhigen Bereiche mit Mustern auf dem Boden oder Hindernisse dauern lange. Da fährt der
Roboter zumindest von außen betrachtet total unlogisch drauf rum. Hier mal ein Beispiel
mit drei kleinen Hindernissen. Schaukelpferd, Stoffmaus und Plastikspielzeug. Fast eine halbe
Stunde dauert nur das Saugen dieses Bereichs. Ohne die Hindernisse fährt der Sauger immer
noch sehr unsystematisch hin und her. Also das hat bei meinem wirklich gut geklappt.
Der hat einfach so Bahnen durch den Raum gezogen. Am schnellsten klappt es auf einfarbigen
uniformen Untergründen. Für diesen hier sichtbaren Bereich braucht der Sauger nur
acht Minuten und macht in der Zeit sogar zwei Durchläufe. Das ist richtig nice, wenn man
gerade ein bisschen Putzfimmel hat. Dann drückt man auf zweimal und dann wird der Bereich
zuerst horizontal abgefahren und dann vertikal. Damit erzeugt man im Wohnungsplan in der App
so ein Muster. Ha, super befriedigend. Diese Wohnungspläne erzeugt der Roboter übrigens
von selbst. Ein einzelner Reinigungsvorgang. Ja, das konnte meiner auch schon. Meiner
ist ja quasi der Vorvorgänger von dem. Das ging auch schon. Das fand ich auch cool, weil
das hatte man dann alles im Browser und konnte sich das alles im Webinterface angucken anstatt
in der offiziellen App. Mit der Zeit werden die Pläne dann theoretisch immer genauer.
Das klappte bei mir auch ein paar Wochen lang gut. Ich muss noch mal kurz was gucken. Home
Assistant Roborock S7. Da gibt es doch mittlerweile halbwegs eine gescheite Integration, oder?
Was braucht man? Hux? Nee. Den Cloud Map Extractor. Ach, für die Bilder, oder wie?
Also, was braucht man? Die App? Schreib halt, was Sache ist. Ja, das war's.
Ja, Simple. Ah ja, okay. Die Xiaomi App Integration braucht man dann. Die Cloud Integration. Ja,
okay. Okay. Es ist halt, es widerstrebt mir. Es widerstrebt mir einfach, dass ich so ein
Cloud Only...
Irgendwann fing das System dann sogar an, die Räume korrekt automatisch zu benennen.
Also Schlafzimmer, Esszimmer, Badezimmer. Das ist cool, aber es gab auch immer wieder
Fehler. Am seltsamsten war, dass ich irgendwann einen Bereich einfach seitlich umdrehte auf
der Karte und der Roboter dann wirklich komplett falsch fuhr und auch...
Das hatte ich im Wohnzimmer. Ich hatte was ähnliches im Wohnzimmer. Der Roboter, also
der Stoffzimmer, der war durch den Fernseher, durch das Display vom Fernseher, wahrscheinlich
weil das irgendwie reflektiert hat oder so, war der verwirrt, sodass mit jedem Hin- und
Zurückfahren wurde das Wohnzimmer auf der Map größer. Also der ist nie fertig geworden.
Der ist hin und zurückgefahren und dann ist das Wohnzimmer immer gewachsen. Also bei ihm
in der Logik, ja. Und dementsprechend ist er mehr oder weniger auch immer an den gleichen
Stellen aufwärts und abwärts gefahren, weil das Wohnzimmer quasi gewachsen ist, während
er gefahren ist. Ja, das hat ihn verwirrt. Aber das gab ein Update und dann war es gut,
dann war alles in Ordnung. Real Estate. Zumindest in der App.
Beim Neuerstellen passierten dann allerdings wieder ein paar komische Fehler. So war nach
Meinung des Roboters das Badezimmer nur... Ach ja, und was früher auch nervig war bei
den Show-Me-Dingern, die haben die Map teilweise komplett vergessen. Wenn du sie hochgenommen
hast, hast du sie ausgeleert und wieder auf die Ladestation gesetzt, dann haben teilweise
die Map vergessen. Türen.
Ach, das meinte er. Das hier sind Türen. Das hier ist, wenn er durch die Tür durch
gucken konnte, das ist hier, wo er durch die Tür durchgucken konnte. Hier, da konnte er
durch die Tür durchgucken, ist aber nie reingefahren. Vielleicht war es auch nicht die Tür, sondern
der Flur, wo es in Flur geht?
Das ist eine gute, gute Funktion.
Ich würde sagen, dass der Roborock S7 Max-V ungefähr dreiviertel so gut saugt, wie mein
normaler Kabelsauger und der Wischer etwa halb so gut wischt, wie ich mit einem normalen
Feudel. Das liegt aber auch daran, dass ich den Roborock immer ohne Reinigungsmittel
verwendet habe, denn mein unversiegelt...
Ja, habe ich auch, wie gesagt, ich habe noch gar nicht diese Wischfunktion verwendet,
aber wenn, würde ich es auch nicht mit Spülmittel oder so, keine Ahnung, wäre mir auch nichts.
Ich bin mir da echt unsicher. Außerdem sagt Roborock, man solle unbedingt das Original
Roborock...
Ja, bla, bla, bla.
Ja, und das habe ich nur bei AliExpress zum Kaufen gefunden und das fand ich ein bisschen
komisch. Reinigungsmittel aus...
AliExpress, ah, ist klar.
So fand ich das ein bisschen problematisch. Verbrauchsmaterialien wie die Staubsaugerbeutel
und die Wischtücher gibt es nur in wenigen Shops zu kaufen und dann sind sie oft auch
nicht klar benannt. Ich hatte mir beispielsweise neue Staubsaugerbeutel bestellt, die hießen
Roborock Original S7 Staubbauöl für S7 Absaugstationen, sind aber die falschen, die sind nämlich
für die Absaugstationen ohne Wischwasser, das muss man wissen, dass es die auch...
Dass die den Scheiß nicht hinkriegen, Alter.
Muss ich nicht.
Apropos Verbrauchsmaterialien, eigentlich sollte die App einem sagen, was man wann tauschen
oder reinigen muss. Einige Sachen werden auch tatsächlich über Sensoren erkannt, wie
zum Beispiel, wenn der Schmutzwassertank voll ist. Andere Sachen funktionieren über einen
mittelaufenden Timer. Wenn x Arbeitsstunden um sind, wird einem der Austausch empfohlen,
zum Beispiel der Seitenbürste. Roborock bewirbt ja die Station als selbstreinigend, als mehrere
Wochen autark laufend. Ich dachte deshalb anfangs, ja geil, leere ich den Bums halt
aus, wenn er voll ist und sonst muss ich mich nicht umkümmern. Aber das war nicht so eine
gute Idee. Der Schmutzwassertank stank nämlich vor kurzem Zeit erbärmlich.
Das kann ich mir vorstellen, Alter.
Ganz ehrlich, ich würd den auch nicht wischen lassen bei mir. Ich hab eh überall Teppich
außer im Bad. Da ist das mit Wischen eh nix. Und da reicht's, wenn er auch mal einfach
drüber sorgte.
Also nicht mit geschlossenem Tank, sondern wenn man den aufgemacht hat. Oben drauf schwammen
ekelige Kulturen. Ja und auch in der Station selbst war es richtig ekelig. Als ich einmal
aus dem Urlaub zurück kam und da mal reinschaute, ja guck mal, IGIT oder, dass man da sauber
machen muss. Okay, ich hätte da auch drauf kommen können, aber ich dachte halt, dass
mir das die App schon mitteilt, weil die ja auch sonst bei jedem Piep sich meldet,
zum Beispiel, dass ich die völlig sauberen Sensoren reinigen soll und so was.
Was mit dem Gammelgeruch übrigens etwas geholfen hat, war ein Schnapsglas Essigessenz im Frischwasser.
Aber auch nur ein bisschen, denn leider wird der nasse Lappen nicht getrocknet, wenn der
fertig ist. Das können Konkurrenzmodelle besser, die haben da so ein Föhn eingebaut.
Kurz vor Verabschiedung dieses Videos popte in der Roborock App übrigens auf einmal eine
Trocknungsfunktion auf. Ich hatte mich schon gefreut, aber man benötigt dafür ein zusätzliches
Trocknungsmodul für über 100 Euro, das es bislang nur in China gibt. Ja und wenn der
nasse Lappen da unten einfach drin liegt, wird er dann natürlich ziemlich leicht stockig
und die Pilze vermehren sich. Deshalb muss man den Lappen eigentlich nach jedem Lauf
manuell abhängen. Wie gesagt, ich würde ihn eben auf keinen Fall wischen lassen. Hätte
ich jetzt... Habe ich schon bei mir auch noch nicht gemacht. Um den Schlusswasserbehälter
muss man mindestens einmal die Woche auslernen, würde ich so über den Daumen gepeilt sagen,
auch wenn er noch lange nicht voll ist. Ja, aber ihr merkt schon, wenn man da eh ständig
dran rumfummeln muss, wozu braucht man denn... Das Fire HD, nee, hat alles funktioniert.
...eure Selbstreinigungsstation. Da kann man noch eigentlich direkt den Lappen... Da ist
es, guck, guck, hier, da. Ah, da ist es....per Hand reinigen und halt das Wischwasser in
den Sauger direkt reinkippen. Ja, habt ihr recht, würde ich auch so sehen, aber ich muss
sagen, was ich auf jeden Fall als deutliche Arbeitserleichterung empfand, dass der Staubbehälter
automatisch geleert wird. Dazu hätte ich nämlich echt keinen Bock, das ständig manuell
machen zu müssen. Dafür finde ich die Station also super. Man könnte dafür die reine Absaugstation
nehmen, also die ohne Wasser. Die kostet einzeln 280 Euro, also ein paar hundert Euro weniger
als... Ganz ehrlich, aber 1000 Euro ist schon mal echt eine Hausnummer. Dafür kriege ich
fast ein neues Huftor....von mir getestete Ultrastation, aber die habe ich nicht testen
können. Ach ja, woran man auch immer denken sollte, immer nach ein paar Reinigungsläufen
die Haupt- und Seitenwüste auf Haare untersuchen. Da sind leider oft ganze Büschel eingerollt.
Staubsaugerroboter-Veteranen sagen jetzt, ja klar, das weiß man doch. Also ich wusste
das vorher nicht und finde das auch nicht sehr elegant, immer in so Haare umzuzwirbeln.
Okay, das betrifft natürlich vor allem Leute mit langen Haaren oder Haustieren, aber...
Wie kommt man jetzt auf Huftor? Ganz einfach, weil ich gerade gucke, wie ich das am besten
mit meinem Huftor mache. Also mein Fazit nach einem halben Jahr. Mich nervt vieles an
dem Teil, aber was ich absolut safe sagen kann, der Roboter hat dafür gesorgt, dass meine
Böden sauberer sind als vorher. Das liegt aber auch daran, dass es einfach Spaß macht,
dem Ding bei der Arbeit zuzugucken. Aber vor allem habe ich das irgendwann als Challenge
gesehen, die Wohnung immer so vorzubereiten, dass der Sauger alle Zimmer problemlos durchfeudelt
und saugt, ohne sich festzufahren. Ein paar Minuten dauert das immer, die Teppiche entsprechend
einzuklappen, mögliche Schlingpflanzen aus dem Weg zu räumen, VR-Headsets aufzuheben,
etc. Aber gleichzeitig räume ich dann halt auch ein bisschen auf. Und es ist also so
eine Art Gamification. Die Belohnung, dass ich die Wohnung aufräume, ist, dass der Roboter
da problemlos durchfahren kann und ich mir das in dieser coolen Video an sich anschauen
kann, wenn ich will. Und ich danach glänzende Böden habe. Also glänzend jetzt ohne Reinigungsmittel,
nicht unbedingt, aber schon einigermaßen sauber. Ich muss auch wirklich sagen, dass
ich das Teil sehr ungern wieder zurückgebe. Ich habe mich echt dran gewöhnt. Aber ich
weiß nicht, ob ich 1400 Euro dafür ausgeben würde. Dafür sind viele Sachen einfach noch
nicht gut genug. Vor allem die ganze Schmutzwasser-Pilz-Problematik finde ich unangenehm. Ich würde mir da zumindest
eine Erinnerung finden, einmal pro Woche das Teil sauber zu machen. Ich werde erstmal wieder
beim 0815 Standard-Staubsauger bleiben. Wie sind da eure Erfahrungen mit Saug und oder
Wischrobotern? Ja, wie gesagt, ich hatte einen und jetzt bin ich wieder beim normalen Staubsauger.
Und ich denke dabei bleibt es auch erstmal. Mal gucken, also wenn es mal was gibt mit Absaugstation,
nur trocken, ich will nichts wischen oder so, also nur saugen, also wenn es mal was gibt
mit Absaugstation und dann irgendwie noch zu einem halbwegs normalen Preis und dass
es nicht nur mit der offiziellen App und nur China-Chinesen-Cloud geht, dann überlege
ich mir vielleicht nochmal, aber das wird wahrscheinlich in nächster Zeit eh nicht
passieren. Es würde mir ja schon reichen, wenn es irgendwie, es müsste doch nicht mal
so gut sein, es würde reichen, wenn es schon weniger aufwendig ist, aber war es bei meinem
halt nicht. Okay, dann ersetzt China-Cloud durch Cloud an sich. Aber ich will kein Staubsauger-Roboter,
der nur funktioniert, wenn man irgendwo seine Daten in irgendeine Cloud lädt und in eine
chinesische Cloud nach China meine Daten laden will ich noch weniger. Ich würde es auch
nicht unbedingt jetzt irgendwie in eine Cloud in die USA laden wollen und auch nicht eine
in hier, aber in eine China-Cloud ehrlich gesagt noch unlieber. Nee, der saugt nicht
besser als du. Mit so einem normalen Staubsauger, nicht ein normaler Staubsauger, die saugen
viel besser als der Roboter. Ja, ich verstehe auch nicht warum das unbedingt zwangsläufig
über die Cloud gehen muss. Es ist jetzt ja nicht so als hätten die irgendwelche Services,
die das zwingend erforderlich machen würden, dass dein Staubsauger-Roboter nur über die
Cloud kommuniziert. Aber ja, so ist es halt nicht, weil mittlerweile muss auch schon das
Heizungsthermostat teilweise in die Cloud. Am schlimmsten finde ich mittlerweile diese
Sache, was bei Kameras abgeht. Du hast eine Kamera, die vollkommen normal ist und dafür
geeignet ist quasi lokal zu streamen, aufzunehmen, was auch immer. Aber nein, die versuchen dann
irgendwie das Streamen nur über die offizielle App zu machen und dann muss das Ganze, die
Aufnahmen müssen ja auch über die Cloud gehen, sodass du dir den Cloud-Speicherplatz-Abo
kaufen musst und sowas. Von der Kamera, die bei mir im Hof hängt, ganz im Ernst, die
Kamera, die bei mir im Hof hängt, bei mir im WLAN oder bei mir im Netzwerk, die soll
gefällig streamen dahin, wo ich will und aufnehmen dahin, wo ich will. Die muss ja gar nicht
selbst aufnehmen, die muss ein Stream bereitstellen und die Aufnahme kümmere ich mich dann drum.
Also Reolink habe ich ein paar, die sind jetzt nicht sonderlich geil, aber die sind relativ
günstig und Preis-Leistung ist wirklich okay. Ich habe drei, warte mal. Nicht, dass ich
Mist erzähle. Jedoch, drei Stück habe ich. Von denen. Und dann noch zwei, zwei geflashte,
aber nicht von Reolink, sondern von Wisecam, aber geflasht mit Custom-Firmware. Die Reolinks
muss man nicht mit Custom-Firmware flashen, weil die haben standardmäßig schon RTSP,
Zugriff, Webinterface und alles, was man so braucht. Ja, die Reolink-Dinger sind tatsächlich
ganz okay, wenn es darum geht. Brauchst du keine Cloud? Weder China-Cloud noch andere
Cloud. So, ich gehe jetzt was essen, Leute. Pepo-Fett.
Hat ja heute alles ganz gut funktioniert zur Abwechslung. Falsches E-Mode, Alter. Das
hatten wir schon lange nicht mehr. Okay, so, letzter Blick aufs Tablet. Hat alles getan.
Pog. Zack, Tablet zu. Tablet zu. Home Assistant 4M. Aus. Standby. Alles klar, Leute, wir sehen
uns, macht's gut, bis dann, see you.